if you die and you die with any
knowledge left in your brain that you
haven't shared with other people it's
just a waste of a life people experience
trauma I would just erase that things
happen it is what it is things happen
you can boil all of this down to fear of
rejection people are okay with failing
they're just not okay with other people
seeing them fail why turn down $50
million I'm trying to make a billion
dollars you're right it's not your fault
you're never going to be
successful now
what like some people like add years to
their life but they don't add life to
their
years how often and I want a serious
answer to this question okay how often
do you look at yourself in the mirror
and you Flex both biceps how often do
you do
it speaking of the M yeah yeah probably
a few times an hour a few times an hour
I think you need to increase those
numbers I might have to we don't have a
mirror here though so I'm going to be
down for the next hour over here you can
just get up every like
got this I got beautiful little tricep
there we go that's ridiculous is your
workout split I'm guessing it's the same
thing as it was last time haven't
changed it's been a decade so can you
just walk us through real quick if I
want a body like you what is the split
want a body like me give me 30 days
split we should preface it by saying
this how much do you charge for your
time really what do you what is one what
is one hour of your time worth uh I
don't know I would probably wouldn't do
anything for less than 50 grand 50 Grand
for like just like hanging out for
advice 50 Grand an hour probably about
right so if this is a 2hour podcast
speaking is like 200 250 let's just say
for if someone wants your advice 50
Grand an hour if this if this podcast is
two hours long yeah whoever's watching
this is theoretically getting
$100,000 of value just by listening to
this so I just want to preface it by
saying stick around for the episode
you're getting a lot of value from this
wow that was fantastic nope back to our
subject how how often do you go in the
mirror and just
Flex few few times an hour I mean really
when there's a reflective surface I'll
definitely give it a give it a
whatever's convenient it might be a calf
might be a calf flex it be a tricep Flex
sometimes it might be a double front
right I would say mostly to other people
it's one of these I'll throw one of
those up all the time that would be
intimidating like if you want to thwart
off an enemy it's just just like a
bear yeah yeah now like at the gym for
sure like I I'll Flex on L all the time
that's good yeah I want know because
I've heard from other people people that
are like larger bigger muscular tall
like they other people will feel
threatened by these people so they'll
try to instigate some sort of fight
because it's like an alpha mentality you
feel like you've been threatened by some
massive dude do people come up to you
and you feel like you've been you know
instigated in something not really never
so that that's just a farce I think I
don't give off a lot of like let's fight
energy you don't think so no cuz some I
mean if it'd be it'd be really hard
because if someone's like like you man
I'd be like you're
right yeah you just don't care they be
like be like you're a piece of [__] I'm
like
probably like I
agree this is where I want to be at that
level of undeniable just confidence just
raw confidence okay and I don't even
think it's conf I appr translated that
way but it's just not having anything
that that bothers you but comfort with
oneself right well it's like if someone
comments on a on a post and they're like
Alex you're an [__] I'm like you're
right okay cuz a lot of it's like I want
to put a lot of effort into try to like
make them wrong like why like why a I'm
not going to change their mind at all
anyways but like the flip side is why is
that such a bad
thing like why is that not okay like
you're anho I've been many times in my
life I'm sure I'm sure I have and so
like they're right okay it's just like
there's just not like I've noticed that
I can end a lot of these things like
there's no endless loop when someone's
like you should have done this this and
this I'm like you're right so what
personality traits do you think are
negative cuz you're saying being an
[__] necessarily is not a negative
thing where I would say by definition it
kind of is it could be yeah I mean it's
just it's all because we think that's
somehow good or bad you know what I mean
and I think it's just
like all of us have lots of different
aspects to who we are and I think at
different times in our lives we've been
really impatient we've been really
patient we've been really nice we've
been really mean like I've had many of
those things and then if we're really
going to say I have a character trait
it's like to what degree do I have that
trait like it's not a binary it's not
like are you patient or not patient how
patient are you um and so for me it's
just like a lot of people get really
upset around someone calling them a name
because they think that having that
label ascribed to them by this one
individual somehow means
something and it's like I just don't
think it means anything I think that's
because you have this security now I
could be projecting but I would say most
people if they are insulted if the
insult is valid to some capacity and
picks at their insecurity then they
respond and they react and they deny
pick it personally exactly that's all it
is having that affect them yeah but I
think that's just being affected by
outside influence like for you you're
very just self assured it's just like
your reality is your reality someone
else tells you otherwise it doesn't
matter to you it's like someone telling
you you have uh blue hair and you're
like no I don't right well to your point
this is this is a really fun little Side
Story So I was walking with Leila um on
the strip and and some guy bumped into
her or something and he was like watch
yourself skinny like he said that to her
and she was like I you think I'm skinny
um and so like she said it like half
jokingly to me afterwards not anything
she we just obviously kept walking um
but I thought it was such an interesting
thing is that he meant it as an insult
she chose to take it as a compliment
which then meant that like all of the
like these things that we get you know
we toss at one another it's like it's
only because we choose to accept that
it's an insult that it becomes insulting
like I'm sure someone at some point in
your life has said something that you
that they intended to insult you with
and you're like oh well that's not
that's not that bad I'm actually kind of
okay with that it's like well if I'm if
I can make that thing okay one time then
I can do that every time because it's
literally just a choice on how I want to
perceive it so you can obscure the
intentions of other people to even if
it's not necessarily the way that they
intended it right I have no idea what
their intention
is I have no way to know does it even
matter I don't I no idea idea what their
intention is none I don't know what
their psychology is I don't know what
their affirmations are I don't know what
they say in the like I don't know if
they wanted to hurt me I don't know if
they wanted to help me just doesn't like
all I can know is like I could observe
fact which is they said this okay now
what like they said these words to me
okay you know what for people that
aren't familiar with you because I bet
there's a subset of the audience right
now who's like who is this this guy is
he a personal trainer uh yes tell people
why very expensive personal trainer why
they should listen to you
you definely absolutely should not
listen to me um as a first first and
foremost um got into the fitness
industry I started a gym opened a chain
of gyms had six sold those six locations
in Southern California when I was 26
years old started my first in when I was
23 uh took the IP from that started
doing gym turnarounds flew around the
country did 30s something turnarounds um
from there I really got the system
dialed and then I started licensing it
out um and over the next five or six
years we got up to 5,000 locations um
licensed our model on our company called
gym launch I started started a
supplement company called Prestige Labs
uh which sold through that distribution
base of gyms they sold our supplements
kind of specifically made for gym owners
there's a lot of benefits we made
specifically for gyms um and then I
started a software company called Allen
in 2020 that was also to work brick and
mortar leads because that's one of the
big issues that a lot of brick and
mortar business owners do is they like
they get a phone call or they get a text
and no one responds and so they just
lose business for no reason so we wanted
to solve that problem too all three of
those businesses uh we chose to exit in
2021 um two of them we sold together to
uh American Pacific group for 46.2
million um in an all cash deal um I sold
two-thirds of it excuse me um and then
uh the software company we did an
entirely stock sale and I sold uh 75% of
that company um and then starting into
2022 uh we started our family office
formally up to that point my wife and I
had made private investments into three
companies that had done really really
well and we done um well enough with
that that we said you know uh we'll take
all the Divens and distributions we'
taken up to that point plus the
liquidation event that we had from um
American Pacific group and we said let's
start our family office which is
acquisition. comom and so we started
with three companies um and now over the
last you know however long um you know
those those that portfolio in total does
over $200 million a year um and I
started making content on the internet
with the intention to help as many
people get into business as humanly
possible because I don't have a lot of
faith in the larger Institutions and so
I think that if we're going to solve our
problems we need to do it for ourselves
and I think entrepreneurship is one of
those paths in order to do that don't
necessarily need to be an entrepreneur
but just getting involved in businesses
and private Enterprise in general I
think is the most efficient way that we
can allocate the resources of humanity
to solve Humanity's problems hey Graham
what do you want for Christmas I don't
know Jack well I got you an early gift
you did are you serious yeah yeah I got
you a lawn mower I don't need a lawn
mower I have turf well Graham it's not
your everyday lawn mower it's the
lawnmower 5.0 Ultra body trimmer from
manscape well let me see that and it's
used I used it right before I came here
well Graham it's actually pretty nice
for shaving down there and it has two
different blade heads a standard one to
take a little off the top and a new foil
blade to go for that smooth finish it's
waterproof and it also has Advanced Skin
safe technology to prevent any Nicks
from happening since that can be really
painful all right jack I actually really
like this and that's not all Graham I
also got you the crop Soother After
Shave lotion and crop preserver
anti-chafe ball deodorant oh man Jack
you really went above and beyond for
this year thank you and if you think
that's everything you're mistaken
because this bundle also comes with the
manscapes boxers 2.0 premium underwear
and they are so soft and the shed 2.0
toiletry bag wow this is really
comfortable man this seems like really
good quality and this I like this
because we'd be able to travel with this
so don't go around saying I never did
anything for you Graham so if you guys
are looking for the perfect gift for a
friend or family member head on over to
manscape.com and use the code I at
checkout for 20% off and free shipping
once again guys that's code I with the
link Down Below in the description at
manscape.com thank you so much of
manscaped and back to the episode and
what do you say acquisition. comom does
exactly we buy companies um usually 49%
or more um of a business and then we
basically inject our expertise and
capital uh into the business to grow it
and so you know we'll we'll look at you
know we have to have a combination of do
we like this business on its own do we
think that we are a really good unique
partner that can add a huge amount of
like basically do we have an unfair
Advantage with this deal um in terms of
value creation not just like that we
have proprietary deal flow because
that's why I that's why I make the
content I do
um but do we actually have a real way of
like do we do we see a 10x that we can
like Implement and execute on um and so
that's a lot of our kind of our front in
diligence is okay this might be a good
business but it's not our perfect
business to work on and so we try and
find those deals where it's just like
there's no way we can lose and we try to
do those deals how do you tell if
there's a 10x what do you look for what
sort of qualities do you see so it's
actually just looking at the business
like a pipeline so it's like okay you've
got uh x x like basically you have to
understand everything from click to
close to Renewal and so every business
more L is like you have eyeballs that at
some point get converted into leads or
they get converted into customers so if
it's leads then they have eventually
have to get a scheduled appointment they
have to show they have to close and then
uh on the back end once they are closed
they have to get a product delivered or
service delivered and then they have to
buy again and again or get upsold into
other things right so if we look at that
we can see breakages along that line
because that would be something that we'
get in diligence just like okay what are
the click-through rates on the ads what
are the cpms on the ads what are the
conversion rates on the pages what
percentage are scheduling what
percentage are showing what percentage
are closing what's the average offer
rate what percentage are we collecting
cash up front which the average close
rate um on the back end like how many
dropouts do we have in the first 48
hours after that uh what does it look
like over the next 12 months or 24
months for those customers what
percentage are sending to the next level
of service and so if we look at that and
we have our benchmarks for what we think
we can do with the processes that we
have already tested then we're like okay
well these guys are getting 30% of their
appointments to show up and we know that
we can get that to 80 it's okay well
there's a 2 and 1/2x okay boom there's
one we're like okay um I think they're
mispriced on this offer and I think we
can at least double this it's like okay
well there's 5x you got two and a half
and two you're like okay and right now
they're not doing anything to reduce
their turn they're at 10% I think we get
them to three so there's a triple and so
we're like okay so that's
15x what's our confidence score in terms
of like our likelihood that we'll be
able to implement these changes is it
like a super big overhaul or is it just
like there's a handful of things we can
Implement immediately see that and um
the easier it is the more likely we want
to do it and so like I just bought um a
chain of um Teeth witing Studios we have
32 locations
we just bought um and I just got so
excited because I saw their sales
process and I was like I'm going to
murder it's a very interesting business
oh very interesting um I've seen a lot
of those um just this direct to Consumer
products though that you see that you
get on the subscription and they just
send you yep uh I actually I have a
whole bunch from Ali okay believe it or
not from I think that was an alpha M
product alha M yeah well I saw their
sales process and was like I can make
this like we literally can just change a
handful of things around here switch it
from one time to membership make these
packages based on these price points
have an intake questionnaire you know
like do some of the things that we
already know work over and over and over
again and we 5x the LTV of the customer
so 5x how much people were worth to the
business and so it's like great well
there's a 5x and uh then all I have to
do is just double the locations over the
next five years I got a 10x great and
then what do you do once you do that is
it just collecting cash or is it to
eventually then sell that business
depends on the the next one depends on
the business um I would say there
definitely are like I used to give
probably like I always wanted to hold
everything forever but I think there are
times where it does make where where
businesses get to a point where the next
like increment of growth um requires
like an order of magnitude in terms of
effort that it's not
worth or we might determine you know
what we're we're good cashing out on
this one like we might not be the right
Partners or like we might not be the
right owners to take it from here to
there um it also just depends on what's
on the horizon if it's like you know
interest rates are super low I mean I
sold I sold literally everything I owned
in 2021 cuz money was free and so I was
like I sold my house I sold my cars I
sold all three of my companies I sold
everything I was just completely cash um
because it just it just seemed
ridiculous what people were willing to
pay so I was like okay and so if like
something like that comes along that I
would be consider if someone wants to if
someone wants to buy it more then I want
to own it then I always I always
entertain offers on hindsight it seems
like you made a pretty good deal by
selling everything somewhat at the peak
of the market I think you I think you
cashed out the market kept going up a
little bit then yeah amazing time and
then I think you were in contract to byy
a house weren't you and then you backed
out of that at also fantastic time yeah
so things have worked out pretty okay um
on on the timing of that and I would not
like CLA it just so it wasn't like I
think I'm timing the market it was just
more
like this makes sense like this is a
this is a deal that I will accept and on
the flip side when you're buying you're
like I don't know if this is a deal I
want to do and it's just more like that
unless you have like an absolute need
which I would say on the flip side like
if you need a house buy a house you know
what I mean like if you like whatever if
you need a if you need an office for
your company like buy an office cuz
you're going to make more than trying to
time the market perfectly at least in my
opinion yeah so so what are you doing
now strategically do you think that
things are going to be getting better
what what are you holding on to like
where do you place your importance today
um I focus all my stuff on the things I
can control honestly like I I actually
spend a laughably small amount of time
on like the economy and interest rates
and things that are happening right now
like I spend almost no time on it like
the only time that I will think about
that stuff is just to what degree will
that affect our businesses and like the
only way that those things have affected
our business is just that some of our
businesses require financing or like use
financing for for Consumer purchases so
like you're buying a car you you know
sometimes you use financing and so the
um the interest rates on the loans that
they're getting are higher so their
actual payments are higher and so that
affects sales and the average ticket
that you can sell for those those
businesses but then to what degree do I
control that it's more that I'm aware of
it and we do our best to mitigate those
things one thing I do want to talk about
before we go into a lot of the other
subjects is $100 million leads yeah uh I
watched that and was blown away at that
Pres presentation thanks how many people
did you have watching at that time uh we
had 180,000 people clicked to go live
yeah and then it you know buried how
much work went into that presentation a
lot a lot to me this was 200 hours it
was structured in such a way where I'm
listening to you and I'm thinking how
could I use this in my own life because
it was that incredible every slide and
every way you framed it was like you're
getting this positive feedback loop by
saying because you're here here it
worked yeah and because it works you
should listen to me because all these
people are here because it works and it
was incredible how you pitch this so
walk us through exactly what a $100
million leads is yeah um so it's the
sequel to the first book $0000 million
offers uh which was the the purpose of
that book was to answer the question
what should I sell so like the first
thing people were trying to get an
entrepreneurship they're like what
should I sell like I'm trying to figure
out like what I'm they they ask the
question what business should I start
what the the question they really should
ask is what should I be selling or who
should I be selling it to um and so
offers answered that question is what
I'm going to sell leads answers the
second question which I almost just gave
away which is who do I sell it to you
need leads and so once you figure out
what to sell you have to go find those
people and you can force people to find
you through advertising and so I split
test the name you know six or seven
different times and so the book is about
advertising but leads beat advertising
in the split test so it's $100 million
leads um but it's basically how do you
let other people know about your stuff
and so there are eight ways that you can
let people know about stuff four that
you can do on your own for that you need
other people for and so the book
basically details step byep how to do
each of the eight and fundamentally if
you're getting into business you only
need to do one of them and do them well
and if you do more than one then awesome
now I specifically have used all eight
in my life um for a variety of
businesses and for the book launch I
purposely like the offers book wanted it
to be a meta concept meaning the offers
book was 9 and it came with a course and
all of that and it was it was all like
basically free right but it was an offer
so people feel stupid saying no and so
like the the book itself was an example
of what it taught leads was about
getting leads and advertising and so I
wanted to demonstrate all the things in
the book to advertise the book like I
think it's ridiculous when I there was a
book on Amazon I think I used in the
presentation who said how to Market a
book it was like four years old and had
14 reviews I'm like I don't need to read
this book to know that you have no idea
how to Market a book I have proof in
front of me that you have no idea how to
Market a book Because if you did know
how to Market a book this wouldn't have
14 reviews and so if I was going to have
a book about how to advertise like I
better be good at advertising and so I
thought that the event would be a great
demonstration of that to show that these
stuff and I I purposely because I wanted
because I knew people would come back
later to it I purposely used literally
step by step what like I didn't I didn't
go outside of the book so like the ads
that I wrote for the book I use the
templates in the book to write the ads
for the book like the content that I
made for the book I used the templates
that I showed people to use on how to
make content the emails that we wrote
were emails that we used from the
outbound part of the book and so just
like every single part of this was using
the book itself to Market itself and so
um that was what the book was about so
like if you want if you have something
to sell you need people to sell it to
and in order to have people to sell it
to they've got to find out about you in
order to do that you need to advertise
and that book teaches you how to do it
how important was social proof was it
just a random coincidence you had all
the people in the background because I'm
looking at this and I'm thinking this is
so strategic to have everyone in the
back versus you with just like a gray
wall with nothing going on in the
background I wanted to I obviously want
to show that there's lots of people
there and I think the live you know
indicator with however many people are
live also helps for that stuff um but I
actually think the the the biggest
weakness honestly of that presentation
was that there wasn't enough social
proof social proof for like the stuff in
the book so most times if I'm going to
like Market if I were to like start a
business around this I would probably
have had a beta group have them go
through it show their results or their
changes and then I would have used those
stories and reviews and testimonials
throughout the presentation but because
it was so important to me to keep this
like just this Mondo Secret until the
day I released it I didn't have that
luxury and so a lot of the stories that
I told were actually basically borrowing
from success stories from offers being
like these books work in general and if
this worked for offers it'll work even
better for leads I kind of had to
transfer it that way um yeah there's
always the implied I mean I and I I
tried to use to your point I couldn't
show people yet because the book had
just come out that people could use the
book to grow their businesses so I had
to go one degree separated from that
which is I use the book to market the
book look although before we going to
that Jack and I have both managed our
own small businesses and if you've ever
run your own company I'm sure you're
aware of how difficult it could be and
how many challenges come up along the
way that are just unexpected there is a
ton of back office work that I dread
doing like accounting payroll taxes the
list goes on but our sponsor Collective
is there to help with Collective you'll
easily be able to set up an escorp which
for me personally was a massive deal I
think I started mine 2 or 3 years ago
and in the first year I saved over
$88,000 in taxes collected is also going
to help you get an EIN business license
and business bank account so that way
you're all set you're also going to get
paired up with an accounting and tax
team to help you set up payroll file
your business and deliver a complete
report on it every single month all in
all Collective will take care of all of
the backend work which everybody
stresses about and also they specialize
in setting up es Corps which has saved
their customers an average of $10,000
per year and for a limited time
Collective is waving their onboarding
fee when you go to collective.com
and you let them know that I sent you
that is a $199 value for free when you
go to collective.com and tell them I
sent you thank you so much Collective
guys collective.com let them know we
sent you thank you back to the episode
the one thing I also noticed throughout
that is that you kept putting a price on
what this was worth yeah like this is
worth $3,000 and this is worth this and
then I think at the very end you're like
you're getting $8,000 worth of value and
it was interesting for me to see the the
immediate switch when people thought you
were going to sell them something and
for me that that makes me upset in a way
because I'm like here's someone
providing so much value offering nothing
but free content this entire time and
you're there learning from something and
it's like oh gosh now maybe you have to
spend some money for something else that
you're not even forcing on like seeing
the switch up in people of going from
like these Avid supporters to all of a
sudden just like Alex sucks okay sell
out this is horrible I can't believe I
wasted my time but you you hung through
that to the very end when you said it
was free and then you had the book um
what was that what was going through
your mind at that point could you read
oh you could read the comments so are
are you not internally just like well I
itet or it's it's like um they they
don't know everything
yet so like I understand why some people
would be upset but they haven't like we
the the last chapter hasn't been written
yet so it's like leaving a book halfway
through it's like okay well you haven't
heard the whole story and so uh I was I
was willing to bet that the only loss
that I would have would be the people
who would be who would already have made
it 60 Minutes in so I was willing to bet
that the people who made it 60 Minutes
in were going to make it another 15
minutes and the only loss was the people
who made it 60 dipped and then didn't
make it the last 15 and that's a like
you know from video retention like it's
a tiny tiny and live it's even less it's
like the retention curve on that video
is like flat and it actually goes up
during the entirety of that uh process
because everyone wants to see a train
wreck like everyone wants to see what's
going to happen right so it's it's the
ultimate open loop the wholeway Thro um
and so yeah I mean I I saw the comments
I knew that they didn't know and if
anything it just kind of got me um
because I I went into it knowing or at
least expecting that was going to happen
um and so I knew that would just like be
a even crazier rubber band like Snap
when I flipped it yeah for me it's sad
to think that so many people would
switch after two years of giving value
yeah it's like two years and they get
upset at something that fast without
even knowing anything course what do you
think that says about people that are
watching in
general I would say if you were one of
those people who got upset for like a
brief moment I would I would look
internally um because if you get upset
when people sell good luck trying to
sell
but
um it's people are people you know I
like they're going to be them and I'm
going to do you know I'm going to do my
best to serve the audience and and and
there and there are people who even
though I gave everything away for free
um we like what the hell now it's now
it's hard for us to compete he's giving
all the stuff away for free like there
was a there was my news feed was just
all these people who were upset that I
had given away stuff for free because it
made it harder for them to sell stuff
so like I'm not like there's no way to
to please everyone and so like I kind of
just went into it saying like I will do
what is right by me and what I have said
I I will I will meet expectations and
like that is what I will commit to if I
say I will do something I will do it I
said I was going to do this thing and
that's what I'm going to do and the next
book is is going to be cool and I'll
have a whole new bag of tricks for that
one yeah I'm why why do all of that for
free for those wondering just like why
would you not try to make money why
would you not try to get more of
something I saw so many TW Twitter
threads that were analyzing how much you
would have made had you charged at
different price points I would have made
about 50 million yeah so why why turn
down $50
million um because I have I'm not trying
to make $50 million I'm trying to make a
billion and that's me making 50 is not
going to is not really going to make a
big dent in that and so um I believe
would though what is that 5% or
something that you know but like
substantial I think
it so we're we're going to we're going
to take a segue and I think you you'll
like it you'll find this interesting so
I'm I'm I have my next book coming out
um but the book after that is the one
that I'm thinking about because I've
already written the next book um and I I
wasn't going to write this next one but
it's the one that's been like on my mind
the most which is on branding and I
think it is one of the most
misunderstood Concepts and I think it's
why so few people can build big things
and I think brand is the single most
valuable thing that you can build in a
business because brand is basically
persuasion or suggestion or influence at
scale and so if you were to go to like
the atmology of brand like where where
does branding come from branding comes
from cattle right you see your a cattle
with your brand on you literally brand
them and what is the point of that the
point of that is to change someone
else's Behavior so if you have two cows
one that has a brand and one doesn't the
one that doesn't have a brand you will
treat differently than the one that does
have a brand the one that does have a
brand you might return to its owner you
might steal it you might kill it
depending on your relationship with the
owner right which then depending on the
brand right you you'll behave
differently but at the end of the day it
will change your behavior and so the
point of a brand is to actually teach a
change in behavior and so if you have a
white shirt that's playing and a white
shirt with a check mark you train a
behavior that you want people to do
something when they see that and then
and behave accordingly and so the idea
of braining is basically teaching it's
pairing it's making associations between
things people know things people don't
know and then you do that enough time
like if I wear this hat enough times
people eventually just want to wear the
hat if they like what I have Associated
the hat with if they like me like
Fitness they like they like free value
they like the the values in general that
I stand for they will start ass that if
they want to be more patient they want
to be more ambitious they want to be
more fit want to be more you know driven
whatever it is whatever they associate
me with they might put this hat on
because it stands for that for them
they've made that Association and so
they'd be willing to pay more for this
hat than just a generic hat and like
that is branding and so to the point
that you like why not make 50 million um
I think that I want my brand to stand
for something more than that and so I
made it the mission to make real
business education accessible for
everyone and that is what I have been I
have not wavered from that since I
started doing this and I have two
aspects to that one is like the
distribution of how do I get this to
everybody and how to make it accessible
and that has multiple levels to it which
is one is like is it easy to understand
but also like is it fun and entertaining
and I'm getting better at that I think
I'm better at the easy to understand
part I'm still working on how do I make
this more entertaining so that like a
stay-at-home mom will actually click and
maybe get interested in something like
this and maybe recommend her son or her
daughter like watch something like that
I'm not there yet like but that's like
in order for me to get that level of
accessibility like I need to get better
but on the flip side the context that
the content is consumed within is
basically my background so like at the
very beginning you're like hey just for
everybody who doesn't know here's this
guy right if I had said hey I make
$100,000 a year um listen to me I don't
I mean I think fewer people would listen
to me I mean maybe some would but like
far fewer would listen to me as a quote
Authority on on making money in general
we had to provide the cont text up front
because the context is in my opinion a a
larger percentage of the message than
the message itself like Yan musk can
tweet on the toilet and say like I'm
[__] right now and everyone will
like think it's hilarious and whatever
if I tweet that or you tweet that we
probably wouldn't have the same response
because we are not the richest man in
the world and so like that message is
contain is is consumed within the
context of Elon Musk and so what I'm
building with my you know my personal
brand right is the context to deliver a
message at scale that I want to deliver
and we're not there yet and so this is
much more of like a 10 year 15 20 year
plan that I'm that I'm trying to uh
outline and you know I'm showing pages
one at a time like the book launch was
one piece there's going to be another
piece next year and like people will see
that as it unveils so it's more about
the perception of you rather than
potentially optimizing for impact
because there is an argument I feel like
to be had if you were to charge some
money for the book I do think people
would pay more attention and potentially
it would make more of an impact on those
who do read it than just giving it out
universally for free I'll give you the
argument for it so but I do think that
perception overall people like oh this
is the guy that gives all of this value
for free whether or not it impacts them
who's to say so I I I've been on both
sides of this I have charged lots of
money for things and so you make a
greater impact giving away things for
free that's just objective you'd say yes
because you get 100 times more people to
consume it and so but the percentage of
people who consume it who are impacted
is smaller so if I charge for something
a higher percentage of people who
consume the thing if they paid for it
will be likely to to follow through with
it if it's free a 100 times a thousand
times more people will consume it but a
smaller percentage but a larger absolute
amount of people would be impact it I
respect the objectivity on that or the
objective answer I had to I had to deal
with that because I had to deal with
that myself I was like well if I claim
this like now if you have like for
example a really indepth like if I were
if I were flying out to people's houses
and trying to like do huge interventions
with people and like recook their [__]
like no you can't do that for free but
like there are certain things that you
can give away for free information give
away for free Med in general like you
can give away for free software if
you're really good at coding give away
for free like there are elements there
things you can give away for free tools
sometimes um and I think that this is
from a business perspective you you'll
ultimately make more money giving
serving a huge amount of people and then
having some bar that people can jump
over now I purposely put my bar really
high um because I know that like I only
need one Facebook I don't need it you
know mean like I don't need like people
would be surprised by how few deals we
do like I get 2,000 I get 2,400
companies a month that reach out to me
to do a deal every month inbound like
can we do a deal with you and in in two
years I've done 22 deals in total so
like you look at that over you know
whatever 2 like 50,000 60,000 deals that
I've looked at and I've done 22 it's a
very small percentage Gram I'm sure you
know I'm sure Alex hor mosy knows I know
as well and if you're a viewer and you
run a business I'm sure you know as well
that running a business can be extremely
challenging especially if you're trying
to balance all the work across multiple
different softwares but with today's
sponsor netw Suite all you have to do is
remember three numbers 37,000 25 and 1
37,000 because 37,000 companies have
switched over to netsuite and stopped
doing things like manual data entry and
searching through scattered information
25 because netsuite has spent 25 years
helping businesses drive down their
costs and one because netsuite is an
all-in-one solution that allows you to
manage all of your kpis or keep
performance indicators with one
efficient system Nets we can help reduce
the mistakes from manual data entry and
trust me guys guys there are always
mistakes and prevent busy work from
scaling with your business so get a full
picture of your business and help make
better decisions faster right now you
could download netsuite's popular kpis
checklist for free when you get to
nets.com IED again guys that's nets.com
IED for netsuite's popular kpis
checklist for free it's no risk it is
completely free at nets.com isted thank
you so much netet and back to the
episode part of me thinks what's the
message that you want to share that you
can't already share with your platform
it seems like the platform is big enough
that whatever you say will have an
impact what what can you not already do
right now oh I can I mean I can I don't
think it's what I can do I think it's
who who it will
reach so like I think right now sure
I've got whatever six seven million
whatever followers across different
social medias and whatnot but um there
there's a different level of impact
there compared to if I had 70 you know
across that and I'm still learning this
game I'm like I'm like super new to this
um I came from the business side and was
like I see the value in this um and part
of it is because just my general
worldview is like I believe in education
over everything and I think that if you
if you if you die and you die with any
knowledge left in your brain that you
haven't shared with other people it's
just a waste of a life like the idea
that you could learn something and then
share it with no one and then die it's
just such a waste it's like why not just
give it to some like it'd be like the
guy inventing the wheel and be like nah
I'm not sharing it like why do you have
firm long-term goals on why you focus so
much on branding what you're optimizing
for is it for the next Facebook or is it
for something um I think so I mean I've
built this brand on the idea of Faith
which is that like I believe
that opportunities present themselves
when they're right and I like I it's not
like and I'm sure with you like there's
no shortage of opportunities the amount
of things that come my way but it's like
it has to be the right one um and I'll
know it when I see it um but yeah I'm
I'm pretty patient about it because I
also enjoy doing it like that the only
reason I can still do this because I
enjoy doing it I also have other means
of income I think it's worth saving the
context that I can deliver the message
in to give away some of the short-term
money to have the trust of a much larger
audience later how much did you end up
making from that I think it was like
five million still impressive yeah you
think objectively $30 bus Tak a lot of
exactly yeah and yeah I mean I mean the
books probably in general right now make
about a million bucks a month um but
like that's it's it's not an efficient
business you know what I mean like books
are not a great business to get into
like there's cost like you you there's
no price control on a book like you
can't charge $50 for a book like you're
you're stuck at what books go for which
is 29 bucks like that's what books go
for right um it's it's an actual
physical product that you have to mail
to everyone so you've got Logistics
you've got shipping like there's there's
a lot of other like you have to print
the books like there's a lot of costs
that go into just like 29 bucks and then
you you make the margin on that so on a
million a month what's your net profit
on something like that uh 360 I think
it's still it seems like that's still
still it's for a book yeah no I mean
don't get me wrong it's a top like
there's whatever 60 million titles on
Amazon like both books are top 200 like
it's point it's like not a 1% book it's
like a
0.000000 1% book yeah we were talking to
Mark Manson recently um and he told us
that I think it was like 20 $30 million
when you really did the math reverse
engineered how much one successful book
made net profit yeah which is incredible
I mean it's why Ingram you know like
owns vanderbelt University like Ingram
is Publishers like you literally print
money well the thing that's interesting
with books is that they the oldest form
of media right and so um you print a
book and if if the book is good enough
that when people read the book more than
like on average each book creates at
least more than one other book buyer
from like Word of Mouth then it just
becomes a perennial like how think about
how to make friends and influence people
like seven you know habits of successful
people Stephen kavi like uh Rich d p dad
uh Dave Ramsey his millionaire makeover
those ones right like those books when
you sell 5 million copies of a book it's
$30 that's $150
million and so and now that might be
spent over a decade but the thing is
like Stephen King still collects checks
for carry like still and so from a
leverage perspective it's kind of
Interest like now that I'm in the
publishing business which is kind of
ironic because I guess I'm a top super
high percentage author but like I don't
consider myself on that way it is a
really interesting business because it
requires almost
almost no employees if any like I I I
employ my father-in-law it's my only
direct report um and he I was just like
just managed the book stuff just in
general like the Amazon listings and the
and the warehouse and the printer you
know making sure we order more book like
just manage all that and so he does that
but like we could probably do it um or I
could take a few hours and do that I
just don't what's the difference between
putting that in a book and making like a
YouTube video that's 10 hours long I do
it I mean I did that too yeah so I just
I just did it in every format so it's
like if you want a physical copy of the
book then you can pay for a physical
copy of the book but you can literally
get an audio version of the book for
free on my podcast and not pay for it
you can get the video version for free
on my website not even opt in for it
it's free on the site you can watch the
entire book just with a visual
presentation because if I'm going to try
to make it accessible for everyone then
I need to make it for whatever learning
format a lot of people don't read a lot
of people only watch video a lot of
people only listen like everyone's very
different in terms of how they consume
and so I just wanted to make it for
everyone and the you might find this
interesting it's like an almost perfect
split of how people consume it so it's I
think it's it's it's 25% uh hard copy
25% ebook 25% audio and then uh 25% like
video what do you think the biggest
problem people have right now is when it
comes to
business oh man just from your
observation because of 200,000 people
watching it you have to notice these
200,000 people have a problem that
they're trying to solve there got to be
some solution that you have that they
want that I have um no honestly I think
I think a lot of it is um is is people
overthink a lot and they they use
overthinking as a proxy for action and
it just isn't they think that they're
being productive by thinking more about
the business they want to start rather
than just starting it and it's just it's
fear I mean you can you can boil all of
this down to fear of
rejection like people are okay with
failing they're just not okay with other
people seeing them fail for Success
let's say a recipe for Success what
percentage would you say should be
thinking about action versus action like
premeditating what you're going to do
versus action yeah in the beginning you
need to think a lot like do a lot more
and the more advanced you are the more
you need to think and less you need to
do it just it just flips over time and
you just know automatically that like I
think it happens naturally like I don't
think you know think about Warren
Buffett he makes like one move a year
and it's like he spends basically the
rest of the time trying to make the
right decision and so like you move the
speed with which you move through
business is directly proportional the
amount of Leverage you have with the
actions you take and so leverage being
defined as the difference between what
you put in and what you get out like if
you have a lot of Leverage then like
with this podcast we have a lot of
Leverage like there's a lot of people
that will listen to this even though we
might only take us a couple hours right
to do this so there's we put a little
bit in but we get hundreds of thousands
of people who who will see and listen to
this you know later um but when you
start you don't have leverage and so you
need to make up for that with just
shitloads and shitloads of effort um and
basically do like you can see output as
volume of of repetitions times leverage
equals output and if you have no
leverage then you just need to crank on
volume until you can create leverage and
one of the things that creates leverage
of skill so like Graham can make a video
and someone else can make a video and it
might take and the other person the same
amount of time to make the video and
Graham's video will have hundred times
more people who see it that's leverage
skill created that leverage but how did
he get the skill the volume that he did
beforehand so it's like there's no like
you
can you can work smarter not harder but
you have to work hard in order to work
smarter so you have to do that first
yeah so we just had on Dr K or healthy
gamer on the podcast and he said like I
I wanted to know how people start taking
action in in the first place like like
what is and and he gave me a very
interesting answer I want to know what
your answer is like if they can't find
motivation to just start taking action
in the first place where do they start
if not just
action I think I think motivation can be
measured by um it's equal opposite which
is
deprivation
so you are you want water You're
motivated to drink water to directly
proportional to how thirsty you are you
are horny in the direct proportion to
how long it's been believe it at that
right um and so those are physiological
needs that most people kind of
understand like hunger works the same
way like you're really hungry if you
haven't eaten while so you're more
deprived you're more motivated so money
is kind of interesting because you then
think okay well poor people should be
the most motivated but that we can see
with our eyes that that's not the case
so then like what's different there is
that the deprivation has to be perceived
so like you feel when you're hungry like
you have physiological need to eat or
you'll die but I see more motivation
among rich people to make money which by
that context
would mean that they feel more deprived
of money than poor people do and I would
say me personally like I'm talking about
how I want to get to a billion dollars
plus I'm extremely Money Motivated and
the difference between my current level
of wealth and a billion dollars is
greater than the person who is at $5,000
a month who wants to make $10,000 a
month both both in relative and absolute
amounts I'm more deprived of my goal
than they are and so I'm more motivated
and so um from a tactical
perspective if you want to change your
behavior you need to change your
environment it's the fastest way to
change Behavior like if you want if you
want to get good at swimming you join a
great swim team it's the fastest way
like you want to get great at ping pong
you join a great ping pong team and you
play on the team you surround yourself
with other people who then you can
compare yourself to and get fast
feedback loops going uh to get better
and so like if you're like at home in
your mom's basement and that environment
consistently does not help you change
the behavior you want then you need to
move so then what if the person knows
what's good for them to move and change
their environment but yet they still
don't do it then they won't do it you
just think that's a just a there has to
be some level of something that they are
deprived from so they're they're
probably comfortable they're actually
not that deprived so like they're like
I'm really motivated it's like you're
not you're not if you don't want to be
that successful that's fine like it's
only like you thinking that there's a
problem with it is why there's a problem
like you're going to die I'm going to
die both of us will be forgotten a long
enough period of time so like it doesn't
really matter I find this interesting
and so that's the game I play if I if I
loved video games as much as I loved
business I'd play more video games I
just love business more so you're
pursuing business pursuing a billion
because it interests you it amuses you
or do you have a certain like North Star
like we talked to Tom Bilu done
something with him twice I think now he
says his North Star is increase human
flourishing and decrease human suffering
yeah do you have a true north that you
kind of like always base all decisions
off of or are you in pursuit of this
billion dollars just because it amuses
you it's not yeah no it's I mean billion
dollars is is just an objective measure
and when I hit that it'll be 10 you mean
I'll just move the the goal post it's
more um I want to die with nothing left
and so like what I would what I would
love to have be true on my tombs Stone
not just have it there but what I would
love to be true or at least that people
say is that like that man died with
nothing left to give and that would be a
life well-lived for me and so like I
deem that why do you need a billion to
be able to I just think that that that
having that contrast will force me to be
a better version of me like I'll have to
level up and so I want to be the like
for me to have nothing left to give
means that I've used up every ounce of
my potential and so like do I think I
can be a billionaire absolutely and so
that's what I'm measure your giving in a
billion dollars no or how does no I
think I mean I think the stuff that I do
with my content my books is far in my my
opinion far more impactful now to be
fair a billion dollars $5 billion $10
billion can do a lot of good and I I
like if I'm thinking about this in the
long term which I try to like if I spend
10 20 more years building this amazing
audience of people that I can help and
then I over that same period of time I'm
able to aggregate a tremendous amount of
wealth one it gives me credibility to
the things that I'm trying to talk about
but also like there will be merging of
those two things that can create
something really magical and that's what
I look forward to and who I am today
doesn't necessarily have all of the
details yet and I'm like I'm fine with
that like future me is pretty smart too
he'll figure it out I want to talk about
Solomon okay sure you said this during a
couple of podcasts which is like your
85-year-old self you name them Solomon
yeah and that's the counselor that you
use to base decision- making off of in
this day yeah can you talk us through
the last thing that you consulted with
Solomon and maybe if I didn't properly
describe who Solomon is I'll give I'll
give some context so Solomon was named
after something called the Solomon
Paradox and for those who don't know who
Solomon was in the Bible he was a very
wealthy uh ruler uh who many other
kingdoms came to to seek counsel or
advice the reason it's called Solomon's
Paradox is that he was amazing G giving
advice but his actual life was in
shambles so he cheated on his wife and
his son was you know he had bad bad
relationship with his son and so the
idea is that as humans we are better at
giving advice than we are at following
it and so that's why it's called
Solomon's Paradox and so so in in an
effort to try and get better answers the
the higher up and I'll use quotes here
that you get in business or whatever
Endeavor you're going after the harder
it is to find people who can actually
help you out and part of having or
getting help from people is that I want
someone who has aligned incentives I
want someone who um is competent and I
want someone there's a third piece but
it's there's three things you want oh
and they I want them to have complete
context so like they have to have
complete context they have to be
competent with that context to give
advice and they have to be aligned CU if
someone's super competent and uh and has
complete context and not aligned they
just know how to ruin my life you know I
mean if they're really aligned and
they're competent they have no context
they might have good advice in general
but it won't be specific to me right if
they're aligned and have uh context but
they're incompetent it's your mother she
completely understands you and she loves
you but she has no idea how to tell you
how to invest right and so I wanted
someone who would have all three and so
in trying to think through this I i' had
you know multiple experien with the you
know executive coaches councelor
therapist whatever you want to call it
and I've I've always had very
short-lived experience with this those
people and I think part of my experience
was that I felt like there a lot their
incentive was not aligned it was that
their goal from a financial perspective
was that I just continue to pay and I
was like well that doesn't really solve
problems for me like you just want me to
keep staying no matter what you say
that's how you get paid right the other
piece was that uh from a context
perspective I would notice that I would
spend 60 minutes trying to to just give
color to the decision that I was trying
to make that I was faced with just so
that they could give me some valuable
feedback on it and the third piece is if
I'm talking to a therapist I'm probably
better at businessing them and the vast
majority of the problems that I face on
a daily basis have to do with business
and so like I'm asking somebody who is
basically a solar preneur or
self-employed on how I'm trying to
manage a $200 million your portfolio and
how I'm going to like allocate resources
and like they're probably not going to
have a good answer for me in terms of
their confidence level and so in trying
to tackle that I Came Upon the Solon
Paradox I was like What if I could give
myself advice because I'm sure everybody
who's listening to this is given
somebody advice on a relationship or on
Fitness or whatever and you're like man
if I follow that advice I'd be in better
shape too and so I was like well maybe
maybe I I have the answers and I just
need to package it differently and so I
started having these sessions with what
I call you know my 85-year old self who
I call Solomon for whatever purpose that
seems to separate my personal self and
my older self because that man is the
only person who has absolutely aligned
incentives with me has complete context
to my situation and is as confident as I
am and I'm trusting the fact that I give
better advice than I he
and so I have basically chat Forum
messages with Solomon it's an ongoing
document it's the first hour of every
Monday for me it's like what's top of
mind for me and the nice thing is that
it also can last 7 minutes and sometimes
it can last 45 minutes I don't need to
like stay for 60 or drive somewhere or
take a zoom call like if I get to the
bottom what I wanted to get to it's done
and I don't need to waste all this time
giving context and so um I usually keep
going uh with Solomon literally back and
forth like it's chat I just hit enter
and I just keep going back and forth
until I get to the root of the issue and
I usually have some sort of thing that
solom will tell me that will kind of
like close the loop and I know it when I
when I when I get it and then at that
point it's like I don't think about that
thing anymore like the decisions made or
like I know like I've I've resolved the
inconsistency and so an example of that
was um I had a I had a a big snafu that
happened I'd worked for a while on a
project and um it ended up falling
through because of a vendor and um it
cost me about $15 million um of actual
money it really sucked and so I was
really upset I mean I was I was very
what happened I won't go into the
details um but like I had basically
think about this way like I paid a big
chunk of money for insurance uh against
a $15 million loss and the person that I
had paid that was literally their only
job that I paid a good chunk of money a
fraction of that but a good chunk of
money several hundred, to ensure that
didn't happen and then after paying it
did
happen and I was like this was the only
jobob you had this is the thing that you
were this is the only thing I you for
was this one thing that you said you
specialized in and like what you know so
I was really upset about it and so I'm
having this conversation it's almost and
the thing is the more I talk to the
person the more I realized that they
were just truly incompetent it wasn't
malicious they were just stupid and they
made the promises just because they're
stupid and so it's almost like uh if you
have a Babe Ruth rookie card and your
toddler pours pain on it what do you do
you hit the kid like they don't
understand like you just have to take it
you just get kicked in the nuts just is
what it is um and so I was going through
this process with with Solomon and um he
said I am the asset you are
building and I am satisfied with the
effort you put in and that is
enough and that was kind of it for me I
was like my I put all this work but two
years into this thing in this project um
and it was because of the person that I
ultimately want to be because I'm going
to die it's not going to matter anyways
um um and so the person I'm becoming is
the ultimate asset that I'm trying to
build to answer the billion dollar
question like buing is just a reflection
of the asset I'm trying to build and
that's the person who I want to impress
and the the interesting thing with s is
that like you especially the higher
higher performing you are because I'm
sure you get this question a lot like
how do you stay motivated whatever if
you've achieved a certain amount it's by
not comparing yourself to other people
it's by comparing yourself to the person
you want to be and so the tough part
about that if you're really real about
it is that like Solomon knows if I could
have tried harder so like with a
presentation for the the leads book I
put more effort in I put 200 hours in
over 28 days it's basically every hour
every day I'd review the slides in the
morning I would do a live recording and
then I would watch the recording
afterwards and I would edit the slides
in real time as I watch the recording
and I did that every day for the entire
month leading up to it I had no idea
yeah wow I thought maybe you was like a
teleprompter or something I know you're
kind of going based off the sides but
yeah and so it was funny CU like right
before I got on stage I'm going to loop
back to Solomon like the lady who was
the the the one who ran the venue with
the the the screens and whatnot was like
I've literally never seen anyone so
chill about something like this and this
is like the biggest event we've ever
even had here and um I was like I've
done this before like I've done this
before like this isn't my first time
like I know this presentation like
there's nothing more I could have done
to prepare for this and so like in that
instance Salon in that you know Min
setting would be like I am proud of the
effort I know you put in because at that
time whether the all the cameras cut off
and you know a storm came through and
everything blew up there was nothing
more I could do and so for that like I
try to make that man proud of me but the
tough part is is that he knows how hard
I can try and then a lot of times if you
are a high achiever if you compare
yourself to other people you're going to
beat them anyways and so like you can't
compare yourself to them and it's like
well who's the one person who always
knows how much more I could have tried
and that's future me and I also think
that hopefully I future me has an even
higher work capacity and more focus and
better skills than I do uh to work and
so that's the the man I ultimately try
to impress and um if I'm brutally honest
with myself um I think I think he gives
me ruthless honesty um in terms of my
deficiencies and the things that I can
work on and I am good enough at giving
that advice um that I can I can take it
so for the 15 million loss though what
was the takeaway for you it's just like
I know you did everything you could but
then wouldn't that also say that you
should have done a better job thatting
people to make sure they're more
confident yeah I mean those are the I'm
going to always do that but I would say
this is that when you play with bigger
Stakes you your chips wor are worth more
you know what I mean like if you're if
you're playing you're playing a poker
game and you're buying a million bucks
every hand you're betting 50 Grand you
know what I mean and so like as the as
the game gets bigger you just add zeros
to the stakes and so if you want to make
a billion dollars you have to be willing
to lose 100 million it's just it's just
I mean you've lost money now right up
this I'm sure you've lost money on
things and be like [__] I learned from
that given the information that I had at
the time about the vendor and their
experience and how they came recommended
I think that the decision that I made
was
reasonable now I could always go and
100% quadruple check every single thing
but at what point do I become
micromanaging and then blow that blows
up in my face so it's like uh Ray D
talked about this with um I think crypto
in the early days uh but he basically
said I don't feel bad about missing out
on opportunities because if I were to
make the decision to Pro that
opportunity I'd have to also apply that
same decision-making process to all the
other opportunities that I would have
bought and then lost all my money on and
so like sometimes you just get kicked in
the nuts and I think that um like you do
the best you can there's always going to
be things that arec controllable and it
is what it is when is the last time
you've fallen short of Solomon standards
every day every single day yeah of
course like for real like there's
there's always things I could do better
on I could have I could have been you
know I could have been kinder to lately
I could have put more effort into like
what I was going to say to her this
morning like there's always things I can
do better and it's um and yeah I but I
will say that my talks with Solon are
typically about one specific thing so
when we have ask you questions it sounds
like you place a lot of value and
fulfillment in who you eventually will
be at some point right which is like the
the guy providing the most amount of
value the billion dollar guy Etc Solomon
yes um yet at the same time you do say
things like I do not want to place my
value in some sort of future event that
could happen right because then you're
creating a distance between who you are
right now and who you like to be um how
do you maintain that balance of like
putting so much value in this future
self yet at the same time being filled
and happy in a present moment I think
it's just the process of becoming you
know I mean like I like if you ask me
truthfully like I enjoyed every minute
of the of the suffering of doing that
presentation five six hours every single
day for the entire month leading up to
that like I I enjoyed it because I knew
I felt like I was becoming the vers of
me or was living through the values that
I choose to believe matter to me how do
you find something or how does someone
that's watching this find something that
they can set as their true north that
every single action will make them
fulfilled on their way to that I don't
think you're going to figure it out on
the first shot I think I think an easier
North Star is um learning to work Le
basically I'll give you I'll give you a
different example so I had um I had a
buddy who was in the fitness industry
and he had a pretty successful Fitness
business and then he quit that uh to
start cookies a cookie store completely
I he's getting people skinny and he's
making it fat he was like yeah I've got
a complete system right joking right and
um he wasn't passionate about cookies he
was passionate about being excellent at
whatever he did and I really like that
as the frame which is like you don't
need to tr like first off you're not
going to find your passion because
anything that you start doing that you
haven't done before you're going to suck
at because that's what you do when you
do something for the first time and you
tend to only like things that you are
good at and so sucking is a prerequisite
for liking most of the time and so you
just have to be willing to suck um in
order to quote find your passion which
all you ended up doing is creating a
passion but whatever and so anyways he
had his uh his cookie store and it
wasn't like he woke up everyone and be
like I just want to feed cookies to the
world like I just want everyone to
understand how butter and chocolate and
salt work well he didn't think that way
he was like I want to run an excellent
business and so whether he was doing a
dry cleaning business or a tractor
supply store business or he was
wholesaling real estate it was his
dedication to Excellence that single
value which then permeated everything
else and so I think that for somebody
who's starting out like simply
dedicating yourself to understanding
what hard work feels like and and the
commitment to the repetitive actions
that you have to do day in day out
without reward like making that the
W gets you there and I think the long
term is that you just make that the W
period you're not thinking about getting
there you just win every day and you
think that will serve most most people
is absolutely to strive for excellence
in a given field million percent and
then creating you said creating
interesting rather than finding a
passion no one finds passion I mean some
people do sure some I think the vast
majority of
people vast majority of people find
themselves in careers because they on a
like think about like the first job you
ever got it probably just like on a whim
somebody told you there was a thing and
then you find yourself 10 years later
like off a tree branch uh from this this
first path of career that you got into
what I would disagree not for me I yeah
the aquarium stuff I wanted to do that
but you still do you're still off a tree
branch I mean we vlogged on this to
family about your aquarium and stuff
like that but I feel like I have control
over that like that was just something I
would love to do yeah well my my my
point here was just that
um dedicating yourself to being
excellent and doing the repetitive tasks
you get better at the thing and then you
tend to like the things when you get
better at them like and then external
reinforcers start kicking over like you
just need to have enough in the
beginning to get you going and then
after that like being good at playing
ping pong takes over for playing ping
pong do you like anything you're bad at
do I like anything I'm bad at um what
are the some of the things that you're
bad at maybe Lila is like oh let's go ax
throwing you're like I hate axe throwing
but I will do it you do it and you suck
but you like it um there's not many
things really yeah something I don't I
mean I don't do many things that I like
to be fair I don't do a lot of stuff
like I literally I I um I recently
picked up pingpong which is fun you
actually yeah yeah I recently picked up
I I can coach you dude are you good I'm
disgusting at pink I'm very good at
that's like that's my one thing did you
compete no I've never competed have you
been to Las Vegas table tennis no okay
it's like a club on the strip it's the
people there are incredible oh sweet
yeah I might I might partake yeah no
I've just like I I I used to play at
home when I was a kid um because I
didn't have siblings for a while and so
I just played against the wall for
[__] hours what do you like about
ping pong what's the appeal of it low
State baby yeah it's 100% that is it do
you find a way to zone out is that just
like I I am not there while in the
moment your mind is just it's like
racing if you've ever done like race
cars it's the same thing like you there
there's too like not just like rallying
but like if you're really playing you
can't focus on anything besides the ball
and so like everything else disappears
what do you get out of that I just enjoy
that it's like unplugging like that's
just truly like a recreation like I just
enjoy it I would say the same thing is
true for Lifting for me like when you
have a huge amount of weight on your
back you're you can't think about
anything else you just have to be there
an old time lifter Dave Tate used to
talk about he wrote this kind of like
epic blog post on he called going into
the void and he said when his father
died he um like the thing that he would
look forward to most was like getting
under the bar because like during those
few seconds where he had like his life
literally like on his back cuz if you
[__] it up with 1,000 PBS in your back
like you'll just break your back he's
like it was like the world went quiet
and I think that's that's what I like
the most but I lift I now recently
picked up ping pong back up again um and
I do
business and that's what I do just since
you're here and you're like such a
strong guy okay I'm wondering because
because I I've been thinking about like
I did get on Crea I kind of slowed it
down I picked it back up but I heard
from somewhere that it can build muscle
like 33% faster as someone who's just
absolutely shredded you probably do Crea
like
don't well way to make assumptions yeah
I mean I just thought everyone was
taking it to be honest everyone's on
this everyone's on it is it not you
don't take creatine no I don't take
creatine if you eat a lot of meat you
already have a ton of creatine in it but
I I if you look up the data like
creatine you should be taking 5
milligrams per day and if you have to
eat so much meat in order to get that
much so have you have you ever seen like
the midwit memes where it's like the IQ
where it's like the the dummy and then
like the middle guy and then like the
guy at the end yeah at the very end a
lot of stuff in Fitness is like that
that makes a lot of sense so it's like
pick the right parents eat protein uh
lift progressively heavier weight and
then you're like set schemes red schemes
BL and it's like pick the right parents
like eat protein lift more weight over
time have you ever gotten your
testosterone checked of course you have
yeah actually recently what's your
testosterone it was 124 124 yeah super
what do you mean 124 I thought it goes
up to like a, yeah isn't 500 300 to
1,000 is the like recommended range I'm
below the recommended range how how is
that even physically possible I've
always been low the highest reading I've
ever had is 270 you eat lots of soy that
makes no sense CU I see that like the
beard and the muscle don't you have to
have the deep voice no it's like you
have to have more testosterone you can
be Androgen sensitive that can be very
sensitive to Androgen some people are
not sensitive at all so it's like if you
add testosterone to your system like you
somebody will get a significantly higher
response than other people and so you
have you know genetic Potential from
parents but you also have just like how
responsive you are to anabolic hormones
in general like some of the big because
we the Olympia just happened for
bodybuilding like this last week a lot
of those guys some of them some of the
the genetic factors that they have are
just that their body is just more
responsive to anabolics than other
people and so like you can just be more
Androgen sensitive so like you need less
you need less testosterone to make the
same muscle and so like those ranges
are they're arbitrary they're completely
arbitrary now if you are below that you
know 300 and I'm not going to get into
sign stuff everyone don't listen to me
so I put that as my disclaimer
but if you're you know below 300 but
you're not suffering from low
testosterone issues like you don't have
erectile dysfunction you don't have like
issues getting out of bed in the morning
you're not depressed you're not moody
you're like you're you pretty much just
like you don't have like you know
supremely low muscle mass compared to
normal men then you're probably just
Android sensitive and it's fine wow so I
noticed this theme in you of like I
don't care what anything's happening I'm
controlling what I'm controlling and I'm
being exactly who I want to be were you
always like this as a kid or was this
something that you have developed over
time yeah I think it's a SK has
developed over time I mean I think
there's definitely like when we talk
about deprivation earlier um I
definitely felt deprived of money I've
always wanted to make a lot of money
that's like been a very big desire of
mine um and I just have gotten better
and better at pursuing that goal you
know like in the beginning I just had
General motivation but I had no skill so
it's like I heard this works I heard you
know like you just you you go you wander
and you just have lots of activity to
try and burn through things to figure
out like what starts to give you some
feedback and you start moving in that
direction I've always been motivated
um I've always been pretty high
achieving I don't have the like I failed
school and like I was great at school
you know I I think I had 13 AP credits
going into college I finished College in
three years magnol l i was vice
president of the powerlifting team I was
president of the fraternity like I
always tried to [__] life you know what
I mean everyone's different but like at
the same time there's plenty of people
who didn't have any of that stuff and
then crush it later um but you I think
you can just always make the decision to
do whatever you want to do whenever you
want to do
it like the idea that you haven't been
successful for your entirety of your
life has absolutely no impact on why you
can't be successful right now the the
work that needs to be done for someone
to succeed remains unchanged and so like
whenever you choose to start that you
choose to start that and everything
before that moment doesn't really matter
well I think it's easier when you have
momentum behind you for sure yeah I'm
just saying like objectively if you have
zero momentum and you still do the thing
it still works my my thought is that it
might be harder if you don't have that
previous success to draw from totally
might hold you back in in ways of maybe
being more cautious yeah self-doubt
things like that yeah um I think I think
uh I I use the term chunking up or
chunking down but like the you know the
biggest predictor of future success is
past success regardless and so the idea
is like okay well you might be like well
I want to take this big jump but I've
never done that before like how do I
take this jump how do I take this risk
right well it's like can you generalize
some of the other things you've done in
the past um that would give you some
level of confidence that this is not
unreasonable and so it's like if I've
been really disciplined at school and
exercise then it might be I might it
might follow that I'll be relatively
disciplined with my job is a guaranteed
no but I could still make a
generalization that that's it's
plausible and so I think it's like
stacking those wins uh as low as a
common denominator as you can I mean you
know for somebody who's absolutely just
like sucking a life right now then it's
like if you got out of bed today then
cool call A W you know what I mean like
just regress it back and then you start
just like you'd add weight to a bar you
add weight to the goals so is it as
simple as just waking up in the morning
great then it would be Take a Walk for
10 minutes great and then just building
on that yeah and I think your bar always
moves like when a toddler in the
beginning begin speaking they
approximate the word Mom they're like
and you're like yeah you're so excited
but like you know a 10-year-old says mom
and you tell them to screw off right
like the bar
moves I'm not your mom right yeah sure
I'm not your mom um no but the bar moves
because like your standards for
excellence continue to improve so it's
like if you're like don't use someone
else's standards use your own and once
you can say mom really consistently then
like start saying sentences I want to
know because we talked I think it was
the first or second time you came on the
podcast about trauma sure cuz you have
very interesting takes on okay okay and
recently not to be that guy but I feel
like I have gotten more similar to your
beliefs with regard to trauma everyone
goes through traumatic experiences in
their life it's their response to that
trauma that actually ends up making the
difference now I saw this video I don't
know if you've seen this before but it
was someone holding the baby yeah and
then they like knock on a doorway nearby
or a door nearby and they're like oh my
God I'm so sorry I hit your head and the
baby's like and it starts crying as
though it's in pain right and that could
be a traumatic experience for that baby
and then I saw another video of a baby
that took a tumble like a pretty bad
spill and the mom's like oh look we just
had a happy spill this is so funny and
the baby starts laughing yeah and like
one actually went through something and
one did not yet the responses were
completely different so I think now my
opinion from these two baby you know
tick toks is that like it really has to
do with the way that other people
respond to your trauma and then your
perception of how you should be feeling
after a specified event occurs I agree
which is crazy I'll I'll add one piece
to what you said yes which is that you
said um people experience trauma I would
just erase that things
happen things happen no need to label
good or bad right things happen to
people it's mean that's a very hard
switch though totally that's like that's
a whole different level to this sure
like was I traumatized by the the $15
million loss no was it unfortunate yes
did I deal with it yes okay I'm not
traumatized I'm not like I can never
make it beted again no
like it is what it is things happen the
toddler can spill pain on your baby with
card what do you do now are you
traumatized do you blame your baby like
man I've got all these issues cuz my
baby but you know what but but there
could be but you know what there could
be instances that happen that definitely
change your entire mindset like let's
say you are driving fast on the freeway
all the time and then you get in a
horrible car accident you could be
terrified of driving especially at that
speed for good reason maybe your per
your entire perception is is is changed
after that is just accelerated learning
it's all is just accelerated learning
and the question is just is the behavior
that I learned something that I want
does it serve me now if you were driving
really fast and then you drive slower
does that serve you well forgetting
places on time you might have to leave a
couple minutes earlier besides that like
does it serve you and the likely that
you die in a car accident yeah probably
so is that a is that is that traumatic
or is that like you just learned I think
just calling at trauma makes it this
really heavy thing well here's here's
maybe a better example uh there's that
video of a car on the freeway where all
of a sudden the car is just driving
along going the speed limit and a tire
at the no fault of that car tire comes
out the car flips I would be terrified
of driving just because you never
realize how dangerous it is until you're
in an experience like that yeah and then
the question would be is that the lesson
that you want to learn from that or is
it that there was a baby and he ruined
your baby withth card like you were
driving and something happened it's just
like is is the adaptation is the
learning useful if it isn't then maybe
we don't call it trauma maybe we call it
bad luck but trauma to a certain degree
is a thing is it right because well if
you look at you know all available data
and people that go through certain
things I don't know what that means but
like if you look at all available data
but if you're saying like do people have
emotional disturbances I would agree
with you I think if you tell people that
they have trauma they will absolutely be
affected by whatever the thing is I'm
saying that happen so I gave the extreme
example last time but it's probably
worth repeating so you're 14-year-old
girl and you all of a sudden have this
man you don't know and he has sex with
you he's 35 years old
traumatic I think most people would be
like that's a traumatic experience it
was also just the Middle Ages and you
might actually be a wonderful daughter
doing her Duty because that's when they
got married and they would be married to
men who are significantly older for
alliances for their family were they
traumatized or was that just like
actually the they were actually being a
good daughter doing their Duty as a as a
daughter of their
family so there's
literally things that we can state with
facts this happened a 35-year-old man
had sex with someone that he had never
seen before and that she had never seen
him and she was 14 years old that
happened everything else we do is the
narrative we create around it and I use
that extreme example which everyone like
you know pulls away when I say that but
it's like you have to use the extremes
to make the point and so like if that
can be both Duty in one setting and
horribly traumatic in another then it
means that the narrative is the thing
that gives all the power I think it's
context and our times have changed since
then where now acceptable or now it's
not now it's accept so just just
everybody know Graham that that's
acceptable there you go back then it was
not acceptable back back then fuing
mixing this [__] hold on but now it's a
whole different thing now it's not
acceptable back then it was and
I I think I think the the context has
changed in society there's a lot of
things that are different today that
were normalized back then it doesn't
make it necessarily okay but but it's
the surrounding context my exact point
is that if you have something bad that
happens another human at a different
time period might have experienced that
same thing and so the only reason that
you choose to get upset about it and
then get into a hyperlearning phase
about something good or bad is because
you were told
to well it could also be in in context
of what's happening around you where if
it's like if everyone else is doing it
around you if you're you now today
you're the outlier whereas maybe back
then you were fitting in with everyone
else who's also that's just
narrative like I'm saying as a as a tool
so for everybody who's listening to this
yeah if you have something bad happen
you can think I will subscribe to the
traumatic experience that my counselor
has told me that I have gone through and
they've labeled this thing and then I
get to have I just get to keep this
problem with me forever whenever I go
into new relationship say oh I I I was
traumatized earlier like I have a hard
time trusting people because of this
reason that I'm making up right now okay
cool
or something happened oh
okay moving
on like it just it just it just doesn't
matter it just doesn't
matter like creating the label that you
are now this way because is the problem
not the thing that's the problem is the
label that people describe to whatever
circumstance like um and you can the
more you you'll start to note it like
the more tuned to this you get the more
you see it all the time people are like
I'm the type of person who I am a right
I'm a neat freak okay so you have this
label that you've described to yourself
now does that serve you in some way and
like in the beginning of every
relationship like you're single now
you're dating right so girls like you
know or you'll probably come in and be
like I'm the type of person who does
this this and this and I am this way
like you just give your like here are
all my
labels but like when if you didn't do
any of that you're like I do
things like sometimes I do these things
other times I don't I mean a practical
sense I feel like it does it is
important to have some of those belief
statements right would you agree with
that if they serve you if they serve you
so you're belief statements like I am
somebody who likes to keep my room clean
sure that is a fine belief statement if
it serves you it's a good thing but if
it's like I am lazy I am worthless I am
unmotivated I'm not funny people don't
like me stuff like that I'm not
confident because my mom didn't tell me
enough when I was a kid one eliminate
the because part because you don't know
that there's a hundred other things that
could happen that made you not motivated
you just pick that one out of out of
thin air like here's the reason like you
don't know so you really do not believe
in Psychotherapy no then
the premise of it right well my
understanding is like you are who you
are today because of these well you do
what you've been rewarded for doing in
the past and you avoid things you've
been punished for in the past that I
absolutely agree with to the death but
don't you believe even as a child let's
say you could be shaped by your parents
so let's just say you're told by your
parents you are worthless you can never
do anything like that's hard to break I
think as an adult I don't disagree with
the fact that they're hard to break I'm
just saying you choose to believe it
there's a
choice could it also that your brain is
wired in such a way that the the neural
Pathways all point to you being
worthless and you're told that you will
amount to nothing and it's so ingrained
that when you become an adult it's just
like these are patterns that are really
difficult to break because you've been
told your entire life and you believe
one thing and shattering all of that
takes a lot of work so to anyone who has
that that
Paradigm you're right it's not your
fault you're never going to be
successful now
what okay well maybe I can do something
about it okay great you know what I mean
like there's like there's no there's
like there's no benefit you know what I
mean like if someone like because I I
get q&as every once in a while and
someone's like can't grow my business
because of my kids right like they take
up all my time and it's just impossible
for me to do the things uh so what would
you tell me I say you're right you're
never going to be successful and it's
not your
fault and then you can just watch the
person just wrie they're just
like well I mean and I'm like what
you're going to fight me on the fact
that you're going to be successful great
the fighter showed up so what are we
what are we talking about do you want my
permission to not be successful or do
you want to accept that you're not going
to be like what do you want they're like
well okay it's like well yeah there's
your answer like whatever reason you're
giving yourself is the very reason you
should do the thing like if your mom was
mean as [__] to you your entire life and
she told you were worthless that's a
great reason to be successful there's
just as many people who've had terrible
ubreak who became successful why
wouldn't you tell that person who says
have kids I can't be you know give the
business the time it needs why wouldn't
you tell that person practically well
you're going to have to structure your
day better you're going to have to
sacrifice some time with your kids
you're going to have to wake up a little
earlier it's going to suck in the
beginning you'll get used to it why not
go in with that approach because I think
that person is looking for permission I
think they're looking for an excuse
that's reasonable that protects their
ego I don't think so I think sometimes
people just need to be told what to do
maybe they they might know what the
answer is but if you tell them what the
answer is they'll do it and they'll
believe it because you're the one
telling them right well this person was
saying I I'm not going to be Su like in
the premise I saying this person saying
I'm not going to be successful here's my
excuse tell me it's okay that I have
this excuse and I say you're right it's
not your fault you're never going to win
and then all of a sudden their whole
psyche changes because they want to
contrast they want to rebel against that
and they're like what do you mean I mean
I'm totally like right cool so you agree
so you are going to win so what are we
talking about right it's like it's it's
just this back and forth that people
always Rebel um any I just find I just
find that that context interesting
because a lot of times if you actually
just like put a knife in and just twist
and say sure let's take it to the
Natural land you'll never win okay how
do you feel now right so then you making
all of that Fanfare about all these
reasons why it's Justified that you
won't win how does that serve you it
doesn't so you might as well act as
though it didn't matter anyways and do
the stuff that is required just to be
clear for everybody like I share the
stuff that work for me if if what you're
doing is working for you then I love you
keep crushing it you know what I mean
like I I just share this stuff because
people ask you know they're like how did
you do this by this time or whatever and
I share my World Views and they're
relatively contrary a lot a lot of
people believe as little as I believe
about anything really um there are a few
things that I absolutely believe through
and through and then the everything else
for the most part I feel is noise and
that has helped me a lot because um it
has gotten me out of like you know 99%
of the well 99 who knows but like a a
vast majority of the content that I see
on the internet is there's a lot of
fluff there's a lot of just like just BS
a lot of people giving advice that have
never done the thing that they're trying
to give advice on um and so it's like
when people talk about like you know
energy and manifesting and you know
psychology and affirmations and all the
these things it's like even even this
the statement like have you heard B do
have you heard that it's like a pretty
big in like the personal development St
if it's like be the certain way so you
do the things to get what you want or
have the thing right and it has you have
to be the person first then you can to
do the things to have the thing right
that's like being everyone's like be do
have I think it's complete [__]
because being is a function of doing if
we were to say who is this person we
would describe their identity by the
things they do like is a carpenter he's
into these things he does he takes these
actions that is what creates his
identity how we describe it so if being
is a function of doing then we can just
cut being out right so it's just doing
and then have but if the having comes
from the doing then that's an after
effect that's an outcome not the thing
that created it and so the doing creates
the having and so you can cut out the
have and so it just comes down to doing
and so we don't need to like obsess
about like am I a good person am I a bad
person am I villain am I an [__] that
was the point that we were making at the
very beginning of this is like maybe you
are an [__] maybe you are a loser you
can still do the stuff to win and win
anyways if Graham identified as a loser
tomorrow like truly through his being
identified as a loser and still made the
same video and posted it it would still
crush and for me that's actually given
me a lot
of shelter and hard times which is like
I don't need to be the best whatever and
I don't need need to be in a great mood
I don't need to identify as like some
shiny night hero but I can still run
these ads or make these calls or do
these Outreach attempts or make this
partnership deal and I will still get
the end result and to me that is very
reassuring because it puts a lot more
under my control do you think that you
would do better in that case if you're
feeling bad if you were feeling better
about yourself that you would have a
better
result if the exact same activity was
done no
yes if the number of if I send the same
hundred emails to the same exact people
whether I'm in bad mood or good mood the
same response rates going to come back
if you feel like you're in a really
great mood don't you feel like you could
craft those emails in such a way that's
maybe 1% better and I'm talking about if
we just stick to what the doing is
because then at that point it's like
sure great we shifted to do it but like
the doing itself can just be done and I
like that a lot because for people who
are in hard times it's like you can you
don't have to feel confident to do [__]
you can still get the result for it like
you don't need to be confident to go up
to the girl just go for the girl and not
be confident and still ask her out
basically what I'm trying to prevent
against is the person who's waiting to
be in a good mood to work because that
sometimes that good mood never comes
yeah but the work still needs doing for
people who are looking to get started
what do you think is the best business
for people to get into right now I think
the best business for someone to start
if they've never started a business
before is something that they already
have tangential experience with and so
usually you have parents friends family
first jobs that you have some industry
knowledge so if you look at like y
combinator for example they look for
Founders who have lived with the problem
or Andor have industry experience and so
if you have both of those things like
the likelihood that you will be
successful with the Endeavor that you're
going in is significantly higher because
there's just a lot of there's a lot of
there's a huge learning curve to
entering any new industry and if you can
just pay down some of that ignorance tax
even if the opportunity vehicle isn't
the perfect one you will still have a
significantly higher likelihood of
winning and one of the big fallacies of
your first business is that it's going
to be your last business and it almost
never is and so the idea is like it's
much more valuable to get started on
something that you a higher likely of
success on so that you can get some
faster rewards for the behavior of
getting into business and then from
there get some resources get some skills
and then you can have a better
perspective from which to make a jump or
a decision on what to do next and at
least that's that's how I that's you
know my two sons on it yeah we were at
the gym Jack and I uh the other day and
actually two people came us up to us and
they said that they love the podcast
that we did together the first one I
think that's how they found the podcast
but that was their both people separate
ref that podcast like and one person
said when you going to have horos back
on I said well coincidence you know he's
coming like the next week they had a
question for you that I told them I
would ask you so if you ever see me in
person you want to have me ask Alex
Orosi something you just ask uh he was a
W2 employee okay and he says he really
likes your content and wants to know
your advice to people who aren't selling
anything sure but they're an employee
and they want to make more money they
want to get better at what they're doing
how could they apply your advice to them
you have to figure out how your job
directly ties to revenue in the business
and if you don't know
ask like fundamentally if you don't know
how your job makes the business money
then ask and then once you understand
how you directly tie to money then drive
towards that because like fundamentally
every position in the business makes the
business more money if I mean if the job
is well-designed otherwise why are you
there right I mean even if you're like
I'm a Frontline customer service rep
it's like okay well how do you like if I
had to ask that person like how do you
make the business money the answer is is
if I do a good job people will come back
and buy again if I do a good job we'll
have a lower percentage of people who
will refund if I do a good job the
business will be able to command higher
prices off of Word of Mouth in the
future like these are the things that
you can explain and say like okay well
then if those are the things that drive
Revenue then I'm going to try and focus
on those things and then you can ask
your boss and this is a great question
is what would it take for me to make
this it's not saying I need to make that
it's just asking them to solve the
problem like what would it take for me
to earn that and then they can give you
an objective metric now your boss might
might not be high enough and then you
say cool can you ask the person above
you and um by doing it that way you're
also being clear like I want to make the
business more money what would it take
for and end in doing so I would like a
small percentage of the increase that
I'm able to bring like what would it
take and I think that's a great way to
have that conversation Leila my wife
also makes tons of content for like how
to ask for Rises how to negotiate that
stuff on her Channel as a side note when
she's more knowledgeable than I am about
I do think though a lot of careers out
there will never give you that
opportunity you say I want to you know
make more money or I want to do more
they're gonna you get back get back to
your desk just focus you just focus on
that and there aren't really those
opportunities out there in those
situations would you recommend looking
for work elsewhere I think I think um
small businesses are a good opportunity
for that stuff so if you're like in a
massive Corporation um you can quickly
cap out and get like lost in the shuffle
if it's this massive org and so I think
it makes sense to go get uh basically a
stamp of approval from maybe a name
brand company that you can then leverage
into a smaller business that you'll have
a lot more impact a lot more opportunity
for growth most entrepreneurs are far
more receptive to anyone who says I will
help you make more money uh and so um
again if you can change your environment
you'll often be able to change your
behavior um by the way I meant to ask
this earlier I noticed uh we had a bit
of a problem actually was on Instagram
yeah and I noce you're not following me
back on Instagram oh [__] yeah uh so
following a lot of
as something bad yeah what do you have
to say about that I think it's terrible
I only follow comedy and philosophy
accounts for the most part comedy and
philosophy accounts yeah the only two
truth tellers and what do you what do
you get from those accounts by watching
I enjoy it yeah both give me context on
life some make me laugh some make me
think and who are your who are your
favorite comedians oh man I have so many
I I mean I follow a lot of comedians
like I B I basically follow any comedian
I see on my Newsfeed who
makes comedy regular like if I click
over their page and theyve got like one
comedy video and a bunch of like not
videos then I I won't follow them but if
they make regular Comedy clips I will
almost guaranteed follow them no matter
how big they are I like Andrew Schultz
Whitney Cummings uh Sam moral Mark
Norman I like uh nimas Matt R has
obviously been up yeah he's he's great
um just I mean honest there's so many uh
Bill Burr uh Nate bar baratti um there's
so many I'm just like naming names off
the top like I like I like a lot of I
mean if there comedy I like it yeah do
you like um nor McDonald's comedy yeah I
love nor I mean I I'm a I'm a cheap date
when it comes to Comedy like basically
the only thing I don't like is like lazy
comedy just like uh like uh crude comedy
for the sake of being crude like that
stuff I I'm not like I don't think like
theovon is great a great example not not
of that he's also another great comedian
um and yeah that's that's uh that's like
that's I yeah I I really like comedy a
lot and we like live shows
do you listen to Comedy podcast ever uh
I don't listen to Comedy podcast I watch
their routines and I go to shows and I
watch their Clips yeah the comedy
podcasts are hilarious I think the
podcast 20 times better than oh Tom
sigura bur Cher like I mean there's a
ton of I mean there's so many I think
big J ois small but I actually really
love his stuff um there's so many yeah I
prefer the podcast I prefer the podcast
interesting good to know I don't
actually just don't listen to podcasts
in general I'm not a podcaster I think
like the the candid comedy in a podcast
is 10 times is better than rehear
superal yeah cuz they have to like the
bid has to be funny every time in every
single place with a cold audience but
like if you're warmed up with like
things that got said earlier and it's
like relevant to the moment like they
can absolutely be you know hilarious uh
but no I I I just don't I don't I don't
listen to podcasts ever I listen to Elon
Musk every time it goes on program okay
but I watch it really I watch so what
sort of media do you consume Twitter or
X whatever I can that's that's my most
active platform that's the one that I'm
on like by far the most is it you that
tweets yeah 100% it's me on every tweet
that's you everything everything's me I
manage everything and what philosophy uh
content do you like to consume are there
certain people that are practicing phos
so it's the ancient anybody who's dead
if you're dead I like it that's the way
that you get validity for well I mean I
I mean the you know epicus senica like
some of the stoics I mean I like those
guys um and you have some of the dark
you got dooi and some of the some the
other if they're dead though how do they
post good question what I think it's
like excerpts from trying to make a
joke is stupid fair enough good good gra
you should be comedian maybe he'll
follow you then classic sh classic shoot
you
know don't me
shwi for context guys I got this haircut
this morning and Graham said I look like
Dwight Sho off the rip off the rip he
didn't even say like nice haircut is
like you know it's not like a compliment
sandwich it was just like a straight do
you have any glasses I am not putting on
glasses it would actually be dude if you
had a if you had a tie on in like a
slightly grayish brown suit you'd slay
it thank you you think I just walk
around on the strip I just get
approached by women every well people
would be trying to take pictures with
you they'd be like oh my God I just
really don't think I look like white TR
that much but but maybe I could be maybe
I could be wrong maybe I should put
throw on a hat or something I guess I
think you should change your Tinder
profile to this like put the suit on put
the glasses on and just say like here's
the thing if you own it it's attractive
and I learned this from you you said
that one time you were in the car with
some frat brother and the Frat brother
was like making out with some girl in
the back of the car and he was like what
was it chewing tobacco or something at
the same time you're like dude how is
she not disgusted by you right now and
he was just like cuz I don't care which
for me like I still think about that to
this you could be owning the wrong thing
well I don't I actually I will counter
the fact I think you can own whatever
you want yeah I think you can own
whatever you want there's some some
things that shouldn't be worth owning I
think it's the confidence well sure if
you're a serial killer okay sorry mute
that part but like if you do that then
then chances are you're probably not
going to be able to get a imagine you
owning being an incel you know like I'm
I'm owning it like that's not if you
owned it that's a good point that's a
really good point well so I think coko
Chanel said uh fashion is whatever you
can get away with and I kind of just
like that as a andway as as one of the
you know most fashionable women of all
time like icons I feel like she has a
good perspective on like what fashion is
and it's just whatever you can get away
with and I like that that's a good point
I feel like as modern fashion you look
at it and you're like like this person
looks like an animal they don't even
look like human at that point Runway
shows I don't get what the point of
these Runway shows is at all it's
actually a money thing uh so the I only
know this because my wife buys lots of
expensive things um so those Runway so
most many of the outfits there are made
to look high fashioned and then the
people who are in attendance there it's
like a a huge honor to be like invited
by like Stella McCartney or Koko Chanel
or whoever to or Gucci to attend the
runway show like it's a like usually you
have to spend hundreds of thousands of
dollars a year to get invited to one of
those shows and it's usually like on
their clothing yeah yeah it's like 20
people a year get invited hand selected
across the whole nation to get invited
as like consumers and then while you're
there uh they'll parade these you know
people around and then you're somewhat
expected to bid on the actual outfits
themselves the outfits are so atrocious
I mean and actually wear that out to
like Walmart no one you would never wear
these things you'd be amazed you'd be
amazed and sometimes it's not the whole
outfit sometimes it's a piece of it or
it's a hat or or or a blouse or whatever
um but like they'll be like they'll be
like $50,000 $100,000 dresses but to me
it seems like the ugliest clothing that
they could get away with I to me it
seems like a social experiment like how
Wild social experiment you guys are
being film there's a camera there
there's a camera there I'm waiting for
the joke to come like 20 years later
because I've seen some of these things
with like shoes with a goldfish in them
like it's stupid oh there's like these
necklaces pendant things with a turtle
inside of it it's so s Turtle yeah like
a baby turtle are you serious I've seen
that for it's very sad how was but it's
just
Buttle well for like 24 hours maybe I me
think about the life it gets the lead I
mean the comparison is just like it's
just floating around water all day here
it like gets to travel the world it gets
to like hang out with I bet if you asked
the turtle it would probably say it
preferred that too right I I I saw this
video and it was someone who did a
social experiment where they created
like this new hip store where they got
like I think it was like H&M and like
cheap but it's from Payless shoe store
and then all these people came and they
started blogging about it and like oh my
God this is so cute this is amazing but
it's all just cheap yeah they bought it
was like $500 $700 uh shoes and they
just only used P shoes and had people
review them afterwards the influencers
they're like by the way well really goes
to show you how important marketing is
if you just brand yeah that's all it is
the you you have no idea yeah like like
this shirt oh my God how much do you
think how much do you think this shirt
very nice very much gu how much much I'm
guessing this shirt right here I can
tell based off the material Alone 7 $300
what do you think it is I haven't felt
it give it a little touch man you can
feel you can feel it if you want
to that feels like old
Lulu I'm gonna go I'm gonna go uh 60 $60
yeah no it's Tom Ford oh is it really
that I didn't know you were expensive
clothing it's free it's free yeah not
I'm not spending money Tom no oh my gosh
no that would be amazing though J Jason
and Brett oppenheim give me their
clothing and they wear uh they they had
the broke used opheim yeah so they buy
some of the nicest stuff but you know
over time it'll shrink so when it
shrinks it no longer fits them but it
fits me perfectly so I get all their
handy Downs yeah must be nice so I have
a whole wardrobe of almost exclusively
Tom Ford and Dior well I buy brand new
tank tops I'll just like let the record
show how many times you wear them before
you toss um honestly I don't know you
said that your wife Leila has very
expensive taste does this ever bother
you if she was like Alex I want to buy a
$50,000 purse you'd be like for Alex
it's pennies it's like it's you wouldn't
care no she does that like no she does
she does whatever she wants but not a
single part of you I also she earns her
own like we do this together but it's a
joint thing right like exactly so I mean
I spend money on different like yeah I
spend money on stuff I mean I spend
money on like gym equipment that's like
what I like that's like the one thing
that I spend money how much more new
equipment like they're not coming out
with new machines every month right I
mean they do come up with new machine
they do yeah for sure yeah every month
is like it's like a fashion is it inside
your apartment no so we just bought the
uh the old UFC headquarters yeah and so
there's a there's a huge huge chunk of
space oh um so we're yeah we're making a
massive gym there so that'll probably
cost like I don't know 450 Grand all in
but like so it's like how many purses
could she have probably a lot you know
so but like I just buy you know my
stuff's a little chunkier than hers is
but like
like Leila Leila wanted to have nice
things her whole life and so we have the
ability to do that so why should I like
what do I gain by depriving her of that
it's not like it puts us in any kind of
different financial situation than we
are now like if if if if her spending in
any way materially affected our goals
she wouldn't do it like she's only done
that when it basically doesn't affect us
in any real way and so like why would I
like why would I stop her from doing
that like why why have the money to
begin with have you ever thought of the
reason why she wants the expensive
things and why she wants to I don't
think she knows the answer either who
knows like we like when people ask why
we just guess and answer and we answer
with things that we've answered in the
past that people have given us approval
for so it's like why are you so
motivated Alex I could be like my father
never gave me enough approval or I could
say my mother didn't pay enough
attention to me I could say I had a
teacher who encouraged me early on or i'
spoke once in class and I did a good job
and I really wanted to do more of that
like I could make up hundred different
reasons but all we know is that I do
these things and I think just erasing
the why and the because um it just makes
the life a lot easier because you don't
have to you don't have to deal with it
so it's like my my the two things that
I've been focused a lot on uh is like
elimination of should which I think I
talked a lot about on one of the the
first podcast that we did together and
I'd say like my focus right now is kind
of elimination of why and because
because we don't
know you have no idea like I don't know
like I think he was it's like when
someone tries to guess your intention
it's like you don't know you don't know
why I said that and the real reason I
don't know why I said that we just know
that I said it and just focus on that
and that's just been easier in terms of
like communicating with other people
managing relationships even persuasion
it's like trying to trying to be like
you did this be you don't know stick to
what you can observe and that's just
made my life a lot easier it appears
like it's a part of human nature to come
up with all of these extra details
problems justifications Etc explanations
for certain things why is in our nature
to continually do this and complicate
things when you when you explain things
it's just so simple I have no idea I
know that we do it I don't know
why that is so unfair that is I mean
it's a perfect why is it unfair no it's
a it's a great answer no it's a great
answer it's a great it's like I can make
something up if you want but like it'll
just be made up yeah and and to be fair
most people will just make up qu you
know answers to questions of like why
yeah and and you know and it's a hard
bounce for me cuz sometimes I get on
podcast and like the more strict I am
and kind of to a certain degree like
what mood I'm in I might answer very
much more strictly on that but it can
sometimes make for a more you know
boring uh podcast experience because
people are like fine so we don't know
anything I'm like yeah exactly yeah it's
interesting for me to for you to go from
like Leila wants and has all these nice
things to you where you're just like I'm
just going to get down to the basics why
do I want this do I really need it no it
seems like Leela's very much an opposite
in that she'll just say I want it I
don't need think about why I want it
what this means I just want it I'm not
going to put any more effort into that
there was a boat that big yacht that had
a name on it that I really liked and it
was uh don't analyze your
pleasures and uh I just I just like she
knows that she likes it and I like that
she likes it and like what what is wrong
with that like the only reason that
someone would have any objection to that
is simply because of the price tag
associated with it if she liked buying
$1 clothes no one would have any issue
with it it's just because it's expensive
but that's based on their understanding
of expensive not necessarily my context
even if it was even if I had made the
exact same amount of money as whoever
would be judging me for judging Leila
for for buying clothing like that why do
you care how I spend my money
yeah spend yours your way because
basically them you know expressing that
is expressing their preference that I
would live they they would prefer that I
live the way they live their lives sure
but like why don't you just keep living
your life the way you prefer and I'll
keep living my life the way I prefer I
don't prefer that you live your wife a
different live your life a different
live your wife yeah yeah two want okay
yeah if there's like that's my like no
sh elimination of should elimination of
why and because like that's that's my
that would be my you know presidential
campaign no shs no wise and no because
do you think if you were president that
you could do a better job or you could
do a great job no I think I would do a
horrible job you think so I don't
know I heard this question I heard this
question online and everyone's like
saying oh you should ask people this
question to see what they say I don't
know I don't I have no I have no
aspirations or desires um I have um I
actually had a conversation this morning
about that uh someone's like man if you
like could talk about politics you would
go so much wider I don't have interest
like I've never been interested in
politics like I I don't follow the news
I like again the only thing that I
consume is something as it relates to
how we make money and how we run our
businesses that is the only thing that
like I'll consume anything tangentially
to that and that's it like if I was in
healthcare I'd probably be looking more
about like what if I was like getting
into like HRT like hormone replacement
therapy if as as an industry if I want
to get into then I'd be looking at
legislation that's pened
that might make some of our you know
reclassify some of the drugs that we
might be selling or something like that
like I would be that would be something
that would be interesting but it wasn't
because of the politics I would just be
interested because of the economics so
one I I don't have interest second is
that I'm not very knowledgeable about it
and those kind of go hand inand but like
if I were to be someone to ask me a
political question I don't have any
skill and interest yeah I have I have no
knowledge on that and and if I made a
point uh people probably have an
excellent Counterpoint and they'd be
like what do you think about that I'd be
like you're probably right I I don't
spend time on this like so I I feel like
I would be making an ignorant uh uh I'd
be giving ignorant advice and if I were
to do anything it would just be like
from first principles and I'm sure
there's many things that get in the way
of that from like a legislative
perspective and whatnot and so I focus
on the things that I am good at and that
I enjoy is there anything you're unhappy
about I would say I have this the same
the same complaints that any
entrepreneur would which is like I
always want things to happen faster um
but like I also realize that and and try
to adjust my expectations appropriately
and talk to Solomon and be like what did
you expect if I were to give me advice
I'd be like you're doing you know you're
doing fine and you're it's taking it's
actually happening faster than you
originally thought it was going to
happen so like are you really just
readjusting your expectations so that
you can be dissatisfied well that sounds
silly um but uh no I'm not I'm like
honestly I'm I like my life it's weird
just I mean like it's it's odd nowadays
to just be like I like my life like I I
I've spent a lot of effort to create an
environment uh with people that I enjoy
doing things that I enjoy uh are there
things day-to-day that come up that are
stressors of course like that's you know
any business anything you do has
overhead but um
I I like what I do every day and um I
think I'm pretty good at it and that
brings me a lot of enjoyment when you
wake up you'd say the off the rip
emotion that you feel is
tired how sleep do you get oh I mean I I
I if I get eight I can like cure cancer
so like I'm you know I try to like I got
two I got two eight hour sleeps in a row
uh this last week and I was like I could
literally repaint the Mona Lisa right
now like I felt so good what occupies
that time that would inhibit you to get
eight hours nothing inhibits me from
getting eight hours I just wake up
earlier that's more that's like more
often would happen oh really yeah I I I
haven't put alarm yeah I haven't put an
alarm on in how do you do that forever
upon first wake up do you get up or do
you sometimes think I try if I can if I
can go back to sleep I will but I I mean
there's a lot of things I want to do and
so like I get excited yeah yeah yeah I
mean like I'll be physically tired but
like I'm excited mentally like my brain
will turn on and I'm like o that there's
all these things I want to do I mean
there was a time when I um I had uh one
of of those rings that like did your
sleep stuff and I got I got more annoyed
about the the ring why than cuz I
because in this in this this maybe an
indication of how much I've changed over
time um I was 22 the last time I did
that so 12 years ago um but I I got so
competitive with myself uh to try and
like beat my last night's PR that I
would like stress about trying like I
would like not move so that it wouldn't
like wake the ring up to think that I
was sleeping you know what I mean and
then I was like I'm sleeping worse now
that I have this ring on so I like [__]
you know and um if anything I'd wake up
the next day and get me a reason why
like the day would like it would tell me
if I was going to have a good or bad day
and I was like well that's silly um
because I've had plenty of days that
have been very little sleep and great
days and I've had days where upgr cuz I
have the aura ring and I use it a lot
and I do say that when I see in the
morning that says like you did not get a
good night of rest be careful today it
does kind of put me in a mood where I'm
like oh crap yeah yeah it's telling me I
got to be careful I wouldn't have even
thought about that had it not been now
planted in my mind that maybe I'm going
to be a little slower today well that's
like the Superstition stuff that I've
talked about where it's like um Dr cashy
a good buddy of mine uh he says he
defines a scam as something that if you
remove it uh your function gets worse
and so it's like Bas basically we create
these crutches so it's like oh man if I
don't have my green juice in the morning
like I feel if I feel terrible but then
after a while you start to be able to
only take the green shoes just to feel
normal well then if I take the green juo
away then I feel bad well then that's a
scam like that doesn't it doesn't
actually do anything it's it's it's not
doesn't work and so I I just I'm I'm
super cautious and like to your point
about like creating the very earlier
it's like I I just really try not to be
superstitious about anything because I
want I want to have as many the
controllables under my control as I can
um and if I like I love the idea of
competing at somebody who has a million
crutches it's like you just knock one of
them out and they're they're screwed
like like if my competitor like oh if I
if I don't have eight hours of sleep I'm
a bear it's like well can't wait for you
to have one bad night's sleep and then
I'll just win that day because I don't
mind having a short night sleep and
still working like I work fine so
anyways all that to say um sometimes I
sleep shorter and sometimes I sleep
longer I sleep as long as I can with
Leila I know we kind of like alluded to
this in like previous conversations a
lot about Lea always about Le I'm sorry
I'm sorry she you got an interest here
what we talking she's interesting okay
you guys live I'm sure incredibly
challenging incredibly busy lives and
maintaining a relationship I know we've
talked about this before but maintaining
a relationship in that environment can
be incredibly challenging and you said
last time that you have an algorithm
like you have logic that determines the
success of your relationship with Ila
and if something isn't fitting then you
need to change the inputs sure I'm
wondering not when is the last time this
has happened because I'm not gonna ask
that question last night Jack the answer
right before I got here like twice has
it and then once and then once again
right
after has it continued to serve you to
see it as an algorithm cuz I like to
think that love is this thing that it's
more of like a n describable nondescript
thing that kind of just like occurs
between two people and it's not so like
algorithmic and equational you know what
I mean well I think just for the
audience sake it's not like I have this
uh Excel sheet at home of like okay
three hugs equals you know like a a kiss
or you know what I mean I don't have
like one Chanel bag yeah one Chanel bag
equals two good days you know whatever
you know um well I would say this which
is that if you feel like it is that
ephemeral thing that's so hard to
capture and so hard to describe like i'
would be like good luck finding it and
honestly I think the big difficulty with
uh love and marriages in general is that
everything's n equals one so even like
like my relationship with Lea is unique
in that I am one of one and she's one of
one and together like like I've seen and
you probably have two I've seen like 60e
marriages you know people 90 in their
90s very different Dynamics with all of
them and like you have you guys have
unique partnership for this podcast like
and everybody else has unique Dynamics
for their partnership and we know what
has worked for them I share what has
worked for me if some of those things
help other people awesome if they don't
then ignore them you know um both of us
tend to be very uh agreement oriented
meaning neither of us like to be
controlled uh both of us have a lot of
uh agency like we like to make our own
decisions and kind of operate freely and
so like how do you how do you get two
people together that are really strongly
independent um we make agreements and
like these are like I agree to I agree
to these things you agree to these
things and like as long as that works
for us then we don't change the
agreement it's worked great and if we if
something comes up then it's like hey
let's revisit this and if it makes sense
then we we revisit it and that has
worked really well because we have
exceedingly clear expectations of one
another uh in terms of like what we're
going to do and what we're not going to
do and and that has worked really well
and there's always resolve between these
disagreements yeah eventually I mean
pretty quickly usually yeah we don't
argue much do you have some other like
Silver Lining that kind of not silver
lining but like other thing that
arbitrates these disagreements between
you and her maybe some fundamental
agreements that you made off you know
right in the beginning that you can then
use as rules to decide current
disagreements well I think fundamentally
Lea and I also both believe that love is
conditional not unconditional and
so even the idea of marriage for us has
been based on agreements which is like
if there were time in the future where
Lila no longer wanted to do the things
that I want to do then we're not I would
not hold her to her commitment to be
with me because it was contingent on
that we want these same things and so
it's like similar Mission similar values
similar interests like if you if you
want to go to the same place and get the
same way values and you know what you
spend your time on in between interests
is aligned then you'll probably be okay
and I think the problem is that a lot of
people this is my you know one man's two
cense is a lot of people look for are
are are actively looking for hookups and
then thinking hookups will turn into
life partners and wives and spouses but
if you were to look for a hookup you
would look for a very different thing
than you would for a spouse and so
expecting one to become the other I
don't know if that's the best the best
frame this has worked for us because we
are that way now there are there are
people that I know who have amazing
relationships where one is completely
subservient to the other and that works
for them I really enjoy our relationship
because I get tremendous utility from
Lea like she she serves me in a lot of
ways um more than I would say most men
get from their spouses at least
businessmen you know what I mean who are
like it's very it's not common at all
for a wife to be even close to lela's
level I mean sometimes they're like oh
yeah she's like the secretary in the
business and sometimes they over tile
the person to make her make her feel
better or whatever but like that's I
would say more of the norm if at all in
the business like Leila absolutely runs
the business she is CEO period I'm like
off to the side and I like think of good
things every once in a while like she's
the one who runs everything and like
only the people inside of our company
can actually like appreciate that and I
will still always get the credit because
I am who I am and I look the way I look
and I talk the way I talk but like she's
really the one that does it and so I get
a ton out of that and that this is how
it has worked for us like Lila in every
other relationship in her life was
always the dominant
one like because most guys will fold to
Ila she's in incredibly strong
wed it's like it's I mean it's my belief
at least if you if you enjoy a male
female Dynamic you just need it like if
you are a strong woman You' seen a more
strong man what sort of personal uh
contentions do you have between the two
of you because it seems like everything
is really just business oriented yeah I
mean we we we we talk about business all
day that's what we do yeah um I would
say that the busier we are with business
the more we will try and carve out time
to not be business if things are more
like normal Pace we don't really need to
carve the time out the time kind of
happens on its own and so you know i'
I've seen you know clips and stuff where
people say like you have to have a date
night once a week and you can't talk
about business and like people like just
like throwing these rules out I just
hate all of that um
like if we feel like we need to like
reconnect because it's like we're a
little bit too distant in terms of like
hey I feel like I haven't seen you in a
week then like let's go dinner let's
let's take some time and let's just hang
out and catch up I mean sometimes the
e-obs like I feel like I've been with
you all day like I'm going to get some
space go to the gym hang out you know
get some food with some guys and like
I'll be back and so I think we just
managed that and I think um especially
especially in like the world of remote
work um I actually think that uh in my
opinion uh people spend too much time
together I think I need I think this is
eser p but I think you need to create
space to be
missed like there's probably there's no
time where like I'm more excited to see
Lea than a time that I haven't seen her
motivation is the equal opposite of
deprivation if I haven't seen her one
I'm deprived of Lea I'm more motivated
to see her I've seen her a ton then I'm
probably less motivated to see her so
you think a lot of times in
relationships people could be spending
too much time together absolutely
nowadays for sure they live in the same
house they they literally spend all day
together like I don't think that's I
don't think that's at least normal from
how we kind of came I think you need two
experiences to come together and then
you can do you have something to talk
about because otherwise if you if you've
had the same experiences all day for
weeks it's like what do you talk about a
certain point yeah how was your day I
don't know I was there like yeah we have
nothing else to say so like I think so
like and when we when we figured this
out for our relationship it was still
like two or three years in um we
actively just like created a ton of
space we worked on opposite sides of the
house we didn't attend I came off the
meetings that she was on and so like at
the end of the day I was like oh oh you
met with John today how is that she's
like oh this is what this happened I was
like oh and you met with that vendor
who's doing this thing she's like yeah
and this is where we negotiate what do
you think about this and you know like
blah and then then I go through my
calendar and like literally we still to
this day do that is at the end of the
day we go for a walk 45 minutes I take
out my phone she takes out her phone we
go through our calendars and we just
literally download like how was your day
how was my day like what what are the
what are the things that we're you know
working on and moving forward and that's
how we kind of like resync up um and
then after that we just we're we're kind
of husband and wife the the rest of the
day what was the logic behind buying
that UFC building that's dopee it's
pretty yeah it's a lot it's a lot of
space but they go from someone who's
kind of working from home remotely to
getting a full office space that's
massive yeah yeah yeah yeah um how many
square feet was that it was like 12,000
square feet something it's three floors
of 12 it's 36 36,000 Square Fe yeah it's
12 12 12 yeah it's it's part of the part
of the grand plan part of the grand plan
of uh of what what what I'm investing in
um so we're we're investing heavily in
media um and so that's going to have a
ton of Studios inside of it that're
we're actively building out right now a
ton of different sets for um different
types of content that we want to be
putting out uh with higher quality and
higher frequency uh in the future and so
that's that's what you know that's
that's what I'm that's what I'm building
towards and so uh having a place where
all of my team could sync up and um I
could I could attract talent to come you
know here to Vegas is is kind of what we
were what we were shooting for so what's
what's the grand plan with with content
are you trying to like take people under
the horos
brand no I actually I'm actually going
to do more uh me personally okay um and
Lila and just we're we're it's more that
we're going to we're going to be
facilitating more types of content
rather than more talking ads um because
as much as like my quote brand has grown
um that's actually still been the result
of like a half day a week um or every
other week of actual filming and the
rest of it is just the the the awesome
team that we have that knows how to cut
distributed repurpose uh content across
different platforms so um but I actually
want to increase inputs um into the
machine and uh in order to do that I I
thought it would make sense to to have
to make this type of investment yeah but
36,000 Square F feet yeah well I want a
massive gym I want a massive gym so
that's like floor one basically a whole
floor 12,000 sare feet of gym that makes
no sense 12,000 squ feet a big
commercial gym well half the bottom the
bottom floor half is parking but there's
no but there's there going to be a
commercial half yeah 100% yeah but still
6,000 square F feet yeah gym yeah
there's no way there's enough machines I
I barely can fit anything in there how I
I like equipment I'm a I'm a connoisseur
I have I'm an AIC a of gym equipment but
I feel like you could probably get 99%
of the same result sure with 2,000 this
is this isn't a utility question this is
all this is all uh what Alex wants this
is this is my purses in my in my Coco
Chanel like she could have a plastic bag
and carry her [__] but like she wants a
Chanel
like I could just have one shoulder
press but there's three different brands
that make different ones that I like for
different reasons all right there is one
question I have um there's a space in
that building I think where there's one
of those like roll up things that goes
into a space yeah what what's your
purpose with that that's just parking
that's the bottom floor is half is uh is
is I thought there's but there's one
where it's kind of like a bit of a it
looks like a bit of a warehouse yeah
it's there's the roll up door that's the
whole that's the bottom floor yeah
there's the roll up and then you've got
all the parking and then I mean it has
all the pillars what would it take for
the iced coffee hour to be able to you
know get an office space in there got to
take it up with Ila Lea said that she
would she probably said she'd do it for
free that's what she
said don't ask her don't ask her but she
said as long here' already prepared it
no I'm I'm stoked about it but to answer
you the question um like I want to I
want to there's I don't want to spoil
anything but we have a bunch of new
shows that we're going to be putting out
new types of content um um new new
characters that we're going to be
bringing in uh to the content just a lot
like a lot of really cool stuff like I
was super inspired when I went out to St
Dave Dave Ramsey and his whole setup
really yeah yeah what was it what was it
like for meeting Dave Ramsey it was
great Dave I mean Dave was exactly the
same you know I mean as as I expected
him to be I mean my whole interview if
you I don't know if you saw it was uh
was all about business yeah like I just
want because like he doesn't he always
talks about personal finances and
savings he kind of has his like his buzz
his buzz things and I wanted to like try
and avoid those to get to like how how
does Ramsey Solutions work and kind of
like what what were some of the
Strategic decisions that he made that
that led him to there um the thing that
I find really interesting is that he has
somehow managed to have an education and
information business without being seen
as a scam and I find like think about
anybody else who sells a course coaching
events and an app like that's that's
like the prototypical every other coach
whatever Guru out there and somehow he
managed to do that and build a $300
million a year uh business from
basically the same ingredients and I was
like what I wanted to really get close
to like what made it different for Dave
versus everybody else and so I think I
think there's two main things this is my
two cents so Dave if you ever see this
this my thoughts um one is that the
promise that he was making was something
that is absolutely believable no one
could fight which is that if you spend
less money you will have more left over
it's very different than most other
promises which is our make money which
is like if you if you do this thing then
you make extra $2,000 a month or
whatever it is it's like if you make
5,000 and you save a th000 you have a
thousand left over there's just no one
can fight you right and I think that
really protects him from a from a
promises perspective yeah the other side
is that he absolutely focuses on brand
above everything and his reputation and
so like an indication of that is that he
does the biggest slice of Revenue that
he has is Media like everybody else just
like right hooks the [__] out of Their
audience at all times and so like they
couldn't even sell media places media
media spots on their own if they wanted
to because they have like no Goodwill in
their audience M but he still deposits
so much more Goodwill provides so much
more value at scale um that he's able to
make you know 10 million a month just on
just on media alone he shared that on
the podcast so I don't mind sharing it
um and then uh yeah so there those are
those are the two the two big ones and
then the Third Kind of bonus takeaway
that I had was uh they run a lot more
events than I thought they did which I
thought was pretty interesting they run
event every week I was like huh I think
that's isn't that a newer
I don't know they have a new they have
that venue but they're doing one a week
and I thought that was interesting and
then the second thing you know bonus B2
um is was the amount of volume that he
was putting in and that was part of what
inspired me uh to basically do more was
you know I figured that he would spend
the majority of his time you know
running Ramsey Solutions and then make
you know do his show and then and and
whatnot but when you look at actual
hours he spends like 20 hours a week
making
content and I also found that with pbd
he also did 20 hours a week um and some
of these other brands that that you know
produce a lot of content and when I look
at my hours significantly less than that
we spend way more on the portfolio side
and so uh the building was somewhat of a
commitment and investment towards
building towards that I think what I'm
getting from this is that you were
inspired by Dave Ramsey yeah you bought
this building and you can turn your
version of business your Dave Ramsey
approach to what you're doing yeah
that'll be an element of it for sure
yeah that's really interesting yeah I
mean I wish you could tell us more about
model yeah I mean you'll see it but uh
you know I'm I'm a model success you
know what I mean I mean I think that we
will do it a little bit differently
because we're you know we're us we talk
about business we have different subject
matters and whatnot but I think um I do
it's funny because I've been a remote
only business since I mean basically my
almost my entire career and so I mean I
had my inperson gyms but even those I
ran from home because you know I didn't
drive out to all the locations every day
and so um it's really cool having the in
person now and like seeing people at the
office every day and I think the amount
that we can influence and teach and and
upskill the team in an in-person
environment is so much faster uh than in
a remote environment the ability to
influence culture at scale um is so much
faster and an iners environment so I'm
actually just very excited for our speed
of execution that we're probably going
to be able to unlock when is the gym
going to be complete probably a month
well I'll say it stages so the entire
gym will be done probably in a month and
it'll have the first wave of of
equipment um I'll have equipment orders
coming in for the next year after that
wow I really want to go there and work
out oh it'll be the best gym in Vegas
and no one will be able to
go no one can go but but Jack it's not
going to be like it's not like a public
gym I'm not going to like have private
gy it's like someone's you know yeah
it's my office I'm not like having Jack
a little bit of room for a couple of
Jack and I could go right I mean get you
should take it up with Lila I'm sure
she'll she'll be a write up some terms
for you she for sure say yes
are you gonna put a ping pong table in
there we already have
one got it we game we ball are you
living from the office I feel like I
wouldn't leave like for you to be that
efficient I would live there um not as
much as you'd think actually um well
we're still to be fair we're still like
building out some of the stuff and some
stuff's like half done and so it's
easier for me to do some things at home
um but one of the things that we wanted
to be really particular about was uh we
wanted to create an incredibly rewarding
environment I would encourage people to
come you know as often as possible but
not have like rules as in you don't have
to show up at 9:00 you don't have to
leave you know stay till 5: like you
don't have to come certain days of the
week because we've been a remote company
but the idea was that we would want to
create an environment that people
wouldn't want to stay home from and so
that's kind of what we're shooting for
yeah when I saw Well Jack and I saw Mr
Beast he turned one of his offices into
a bedroom and it was incredible and it
made me kind of think if I were in that
position I would not mind living if I
were single I would absolutely live in
the office if I were single I would AB
but it's big enough where you and Lea
could have 3,000 square feet in this
place and you would never even know well
there's already a suite yeah there's
there's two suets that have full
actually there's three Suites that have
bathrooms and full everything um and the
previous owner uh was International and
so he would come and he would sleep here
or sleep at the building and then he
would fly back I think he was like Asian
um and uh yeah like no she wouldn't go
for it not even close like not a chance
not a chance on on Earth yeah to me that
just seems like so much fun because like
the gym is down there you just never
leave and I think I think there's like
it's almost creating space to be missed
from from from work too it's like it's
nice to have somewhere to go and I will
say with the office thing and Jason you
can back me up here I do feel it's such
a different vibe going home like home
when you work from home all the time
it's like home and work are just
basically all the time but working
somewhere separate from where you live
when you get back it home feels a little
bit more relaxing which is kind of nice
sure yeah so you prefer at this point
having an office I yeah I do I'm super
pro office right now really like it
that's something I've not had in a very
long time I used to go into the
oppenheim group almost every day pretty
much I'd be there even when I was mostly
doing YouTube full-time I'd still go
into the office just because I liked it
I enjoyed just getting out of the house
going somewhere seeing other people work
got me in the zone of working cuz it's
like oh everyone else is here I put all
my headphones and exactly that motivated
it's exactly that and I know I'll work
out harder when the team's there around
me like I'm like I now I'm going to be
able to like be able to record content
while I'm working out which I don't
really do cuz at public gyms it's weird
I already have enough people stopping me
it's like I don't want to draw more
attention um but like I'll be able to do
that at the gym there and that'll be
awesome so like now I'm actually having
another rewarding uh like stimulus from
working out so it's like I get to work
out and then I also get to make content
so it's like I have even more reason to
work out so it's just giving more more
ways to win which I like I think it'
make a great series if for your content
what you would do like you know how Dave
Rams has people on take note of this you
work out with somebody else in kind of
like a podcast setting so you mic them
up and you do workouts planning on doing
oh yeah okay
perfect yeah I I agree I think that
would be very cool part of part of the
plan yep yeah it'll uh I I'll I'll
announce the name because I think we
have something coming out soon right
yeah yeah um it's GNA be called between
sets between sets fantastic name wow I
like that yeah that's good did you come
up with that you did yeah because a lot
of my life lessons actually happen
between sets and so it's like I'd be
lifting with an older guy and we'd be
between sets and he'd be like you know
blah or i' ask him a question he's like
this is kind of how I see it and um I
always like that environment too because
like at least my obviously my experience
in the gym has been so overwhelmingly
positive throughout my entire life i'
I've had so many mentors so many friends
so many life lessons learned in the gym
um between sets you know um that I I
want to I want to kind of like take the
take the audience along for that kind of
same experience that I I mean I grew up
basic I mean I've spent so much of my
life in gym you know literally like from
teenage years in high school to
literally what my career was for the
first 5 years my professional career
after my job was literally being in a
gym all day so I have just so many
positive experiences there um and just
also as a weird side note this is from a
Creator perspective um I think like of
my top like 20 clips of all time like
six of them are me at the gym and I've
only recorded at the gym twice ever so
it's was just kind of interesting I was
like it I don't know if it's like a
justos of like Jack dude but not talking
about Fitness stuff cuz I'm not I'm I
basically don't talk about you know
thing is gym content is doing really
really really well right now and so it's
it's a bit it's on an uptrend but the
other thing I've noticed is that when
you're talking people lose retention if
if you're just static but if you're
there doing something it's like
listening to you with Subway Surfers on
the bottom except you could incorporate
you lifting weights and speaking there's
two things going on I could I could
watch you lift the weight and I could
listen at the same time so I think it's
really Dynamic I think that's really
important I mean you you you you would
know um yeah so we're we're super stoked
about that and also all my so all my
tweets the vast majority of them coming
to me while I'm working out so it's like
I'll be between sets and I'll just be
firing off tweets and that's and so this
time I'll just be doing that to a camera
you know I mean the one request I have
meet with Sam celic yeah yeah do
something with him as soon as possible I
would love if if he could be the first
person you have there well we're gonna
have one not him first but who's the
first um well my so when Chris
Williamson and I did our podcast uh we
actually worked out together and so uh
we had a really great exchange while we
worked out and so the team compressed
that into the which will be the first
episode of uh between SS how long is
that gonna be actually you would know
how long is the episode 13 14 minutes
yeah we're not doing we're not doing uh
we we'll see we we're going to we'll
experiment with it I'm going tell you
what'll be the best if you make this an
hourlong workout and you include the
entire thing yeah I think the entire
hour with by the way no edits if you
could do one straight shot post it to
YouTube no edits yeah including like the
you getting up like you're kind of out
of breath people are loving that that's
why Sam is doing so well just no edits
it's just real yeah and that's what I
think is lacking right now on YouTube
yeah no I mean we we're down for
anything yeah we roll we we roll with
the punches we're always whatever you
know whatever serves the audience we're
we're happy to you know provided it
works with our values we're down to done
out what's your hair care routine oh God
nothing do use shampoo no what what do
you mean you don't use you don't use
shampoo why I think it just dries out
your skin and my my uh my hair gets like
fluff super fluffy so I just don't do
you just use water what about
conditioner I don't ever no shampoo ever
right gr I did this for like eight
months yeah but I feel like it just the
hair just get way down you scub I mean
you scrub I mean you still scrub your
scalp you still like thing is you strip
yourself of the natural oils when you do
use shampoo this is a theory and then
you overproduce these oils which then
makes your hair really oily and creates
dandruff but if you get past like the
lump of like no shampoo then ends up
being healthy I don't know I mean I've
been doing this for years I've been
doing this for years and it's also good
because apparently when you're like like
really scrubbing on your scalp it
facilitates hair growth as well is what
they say you're
stimulating what about your beard you
use any product there um actually I
started using basically like a basically
it's like ChapStick for your beard but
uh it's just I if I if I comb it out in
the morning it just stays a little
straighter otherwise it's just like [__]
it's like a mangled monster and do you
do that do you keep this look because
it's for Branding or do you do it like
for any other reason it's so funny I got
um there was a there was like a a
mastermind or something like a group of
people who were all so a buddy of mine
was there and he was like somebody got
up and was like so this is Hermos
strategy to blah blah blah and I always
find it funny when people break down my
strategies when there wasn't one um um
but I I was wearing like I I just I I
literally am wearing the outfit that I
can wear in the most environments
comfortably so like I can wear this to
the pool I can wear this to the gym I
can wear this to this podcast I can go
out to dinner cuz I just throw a flannel
on top of it I'm good to go um and also
we're in Vegas and so it's hot a lot and
so I wear like the lightest thing that I
can wear but but that beard is more
maintenance to keep it like that I'm
guessing than it is to trim it no
trimming and shaving is way more than
this I literally just exist and then I
come in the morning 5 seconds while one
Zoom
I'll be on zo yeah but you have to trim
it every now and then right if somebody
comes you sculpt it some comes yeah why
can't you just do it yourself I let them
do
it I mean I just sit down he comes I can
take a call I can do whatever I want
he's just cutting it while I'm there how
much is that I don't
know people have been saying it could be
a weak chin a weak
chin he's actually hiding say to this
he's hiding a no Chin yeah you're right
what they're saying you're right that's
it that's what it is it's all what's
behind it that's what it is yeah weak
chin okay one last I have a question
about the Nicorette sure have you found
because I've heard I actually heard this
from talker Carlson on theovon which is
amazing if you guys haven't seen it you
guys should watch it after this
episode that this Nicorette stuff like
nicotine in and of itself isn't
necessarily a bad thing but it's this
stuff all the auxiliary things that
happens when you ingest nicotine usually
which is like the smoke that hurts your
lungs or your gums and Etc but nicotine
actually increases mental acuity it like
makes you more energetic it motivates
you Etc have you noticed the same thing
with this Nicorette I mean I mean I've
been to a nicr for like 14 years wait
really I I didn't know this why why did
you start doing that the reason that he
well I mean I uh I like nicotine in
general how did you get started on
that um I started shwing NC nicotine you
started chewing it or you started
smoking I started chewing nicotine you
went straight to chewing MH
how do you get in how do you decide one
day I'm going to start chewing um I
liked dipping and then I was like well
dipping is bad for you so then I just
like started cheing the gret got the
same benefits and been Dowing it what
are the benefits that you get it's a I
mean it's a short short acting stimulant
so it's a 30 30- minute half life so
like you can chew this at 5 o'clock in
the afternoon because you want to have
like a boost from 5 to 7 or something
now 30 minutes so it's like it'll half
multiple times in that time period but
you can go to sleep fine and so um it's
one it's an appetite suppressant so if
you are trying to like maintain calories
or like anything like that like if you
are hungry and you're like I shoot I'm
going I got to take a call at 12 and I'm
hungry now but I got I got to wait till
1 it's like you can pop into credit and
it's just very easy um it is stimulate
from an energy like perspective um it
also increases short-term memory which
is nice uh and uh I have a history of
Alzheimer's in my family and it uh it's
been shown to decrease the likelihood of
of Alzheimer's because it promotes
angiogenesis which is just basically
increasing blood flow in the brain and
then what are the negatives of doing
that I haven't found
any I mean it's I see I see nicotine a
lot like caffeine like it's just it
would just be like uh if for some reason
we magically found that coffee had like
cancer causing stuff in it but caffeine
itself was fine it's like okay well
don't drink coffee you can still like
drink Mountain Dew or you can just take
caffeine pills exactly um I I see
nicotine the same way um and I also
haven't found myself addicted to it like
I forget to chew it
um I like it because I've if you want to
talk about like associating things from
a behavior perspective like I chew
nicotine when I work and so I have
Associated work with nicotine and so
it's like if you want to get addicted to
work then put an addictive agent close
to the thing that you actually want to
do but if I don't work I forget to chew
it why aren't smokers just chewing
Nicorette gum all the time smoking is
addicting it's the oral fixation smoking
is
addicting I guess this is the first I've
ever heard of someone is chewing the gum
yeah smoking is separate like in of
itself and you know I'm not you know
what I'm not even going to get in the
science Bros in the comments but like I
I I have no draw I forget to take it
might say take it I mean chew it I
forget to chew it so I I have not found
it to be addictive per the science
people that I know it in into and of
itself is not addictive um it is the
other things like chewing tobacco like
the active dipping things like that are
addictive smoking is addictive vaping
itself as like the I thought those were
addictive because of the nicotine not
because of the way they're consumed
multi you're saying you could have decaf
coffee and it would satisfy your coffee
addiction in the same way essentially
assuming caffeine and nicotine well it
would be like me smoking a cigarette
that doesn't have caffeine in that if
that was the analogy right so I don't
understand well no no no like like
you're saying it's not necessarily the
nicotine because you say you forget to
take it yeah but for the people that are
addicted to smoking cigarettes it's the
oral fixation the things are paired I
think it's together God I think it's
both the things together and also like
there's also many cuz like also when do
people smoke and like this is getting
like I'll be very this is beyond my you
know my scope but um people pair things
that are positive with smoking so it's
like you go outside you get some time
like you're working you you associate
with a break and then you light up so
it's like there's all of the other
things that get associated with together
and that's what gets harder to to quit
got it that makes sense yeah but I enjoy
it and if you if you are if you are want
to someday start into the nicotine world
uh just just don't take too much to like
it's like try to get Leila addicted to
it um and no one gets addicted to it
doesn't really matter but um but she uh
she just she chewed too much you know
what I mean uh and being like and she
was like yeah and she was like uh this
isn't for me I was like well that's like
drinking a whole bottle of vodka and and
saying like alcohol is in for me I was
like take a shot see how you feel um and
I think the same thing with nicotine is
like chew a half a milligram and just
see how you feel and uh and go from
there I mean I chew a ton but I just
like it so whatever I do believe that we
probably have to put some sort of
disclaimer here yeah yeah absolutely
coffee hour people you know we're not
knowledgeable on this subject
intuitively I would say don't do it but
you do have somebody that says it has
positively affected their life do in the
same way that Tucker Carlson said that
it has positively affected his life yeah
but I don't know I've just heard bad
things that's what they taught me in
scho in my official stance is don't do
it and it doesn't affect me what you do
so like and what I do doesn't affect you
it's fine I have accepted whatever risks
yeah come with it I enjoy it and if I
die five years younger it's okay all
right fair enough that's so fascinating
the laugh the laugh at the end let me
just double check check my notes real
quick yeah I hit everything in my notes
you hit everything in why you need to
live a long time anyways why do you need
to live a long time right well because
compared to a thousand years
assuming our only life our only
opportunity at anything right then
wouldn't you want to extend
it not necessarily I think there's a
difference between Health span and
workspan and lifespan like some people
like add years to their life but they
don't add life to their years that's
great I like that a lot that's a
fantastic quote you've tweeted that I'm
guessing no I'm sure some should that's
a great tweet right there cool yeah you
make sure you have that recorded because
that that was a great I feel like that
one
yeah that was a great look you're
like do you have any other tricks like
the Solomon chats yeah that you employ
to be better off sure I think um I have
a lot of frames on dealing with stress
and um missed
expectations uh because I think um if
you're in business or really just in
life in general like you're bound to
have expectations that are not met and
so I just have a number of to your word
tricks um that I've used so like one of
them is one that I call the frame of the
veteran which I got from Dr cashy um
which is basically like something bad
happens and then you imagine that it
happens a thousand times in a row after
that and then you think okay well how
would I feel on the thousandth time of
this happening and usually on the
thousandth time you would have already
habituated to it and just be a part or a
fact of life and it's like well if
that's how I can feel about it then then
I might as well feel about it now that
way now and so I actually the first time
I ever used it I had um I just bought
this this sounds so hokey um I got this
flanel shirt that I really liked it was
like a color scheme I thought was cool
and um uh the maid that I had shrunk it
and uh I was like super annoyed and I
thought to myself I was like well if
everything that she ever did trunk and
every time I wash something it Shunk
then I wouldn't be upset about it cuz it
just would be how clothes work in the
dryer or so if that's how it always was
then I wouldn't be upset about it so if
I can choose to not be upset about it
then then I won't be upset about it now
and then it was over and so it's like
having like Frameworks like that um that
have that have served me really well
like the the reason I had the the time
one uh when we just talked about like
lifespan is like when my cat Bill died I
was super bummed because I really liked
the cat he died at like 18 months so it
was kind of like weird it was like a
freak you know odd death um and I
remember being sad about it I was like
why am I sad like what like why am I sad
um and I was like I feel like it's not
fair that he lived such a short life I
was like okay so that means that I had
an expectation that he would live longer
than he did I was like what
if cats only lived six months and I got
to hang out with Bill for 18 months well
then I'd be like well [__] I I mean he
lived a good long life I mean I got him
three times longer than most people get
their cats and and so then all of a
sudden like my sadness was like it
shifted to like more of an appreciation
for the time that I had with him and so
it was it was simply just shifting my
expectation around what I I expected or
I demanded of the universe that my cat
should live longer but like but why and
then um I think about that within the
context of like our lives because you
know if all humans live to 20 if we like
34 I'm like dude I'm murdering it but
like within the context of like all time
we all don't live long at all and so if
I got to live the way that I wanted to
live for the extent of my life it's only
the expectation that I would deserve to
or demand that I live longer and have
that unmet which is the thing that would
cause me to be more upset but if if I
make life choices that cause me to live
till 75 versus
85 like the lifespan is still the
lifespan and the only thing I lose is
the present so all of these things what
I like about it is that it's just a
change in perspective it's not a change
in what is it's just a different
framework of Mind how you see it and
that makes that makes all the difference
yeah and that's and that's um you know
like one of the other frames I use is uh
is just zooming all the way out which is
one of my favorites which is just uh
like you like you have this instance
that bothers you whatever happened I
lose $15 million and be really upset
about it and then I just like Zoom all
the way out and I'm like you know far
enough out you can't even see the Earth
and I just like remind myself of that
and then I'm like okay this just doesn't
matter and then I zoom back in again and
so um I usually play with time and space
in terms of uh trying to reframe uh
whatever the issue is that I'm upset
about and think like what what is what
is the expectation that I have and how
is it unmet and how can I shift that
expectation and what if the expectation
were completely different what if every
time I drove there was always 20 minutes
of traffic would I still be upset
probably not because it would be just
like how it always is and so like using
those things on a regular basis I think
have allowed me to make better decisions
and be a little bit less emotional or
reactive to bad news um and I think if
you compound that like small amount of
space that you can create for yourself
for an extended period of time you can
make better decisions and so that's
probably been to answer your question
like some of the tricks that um have
been really useful for me I'm wondering
because you spend a lot of your time
working and it seems like you have this
routine every single day is somewhat
similar are you concerned that you're
spending some period of time in your
life that a lot of people would deem
like the golden years doing the same
thing over and over again rather than
like openness to experience and maybe
trying traveling or trying and going
this doing this new hobby like this ping
pong thing right doing a new thing and
experiencing it and then what if it's
like 10 times better than whatever you
had what if you allocated a certain
percentage of your time on a weekly
basis to try out something new well one
I wouldn't know if there was something
that was better mhm and so that doesn't
bother me very much like there could be
some I'm sure there's something that
could be hypothetically better but I
also would hedonistically adapt to it
anyways and probably return right back
to my Baseline I mean there are people
who live in Africa who never leave the
tribe and are happier than we are and so
like I don't think finding out more
things is the is like the path um but uh
for me to somebody who would criticize
my quote way of living um I do exactly
what I want with as a highest percentage
of my day as I humanly can with the
people that I want to do it with and so
like I would say you know because I I I
get uh criticized from family still to a
degree that I quote work too much but
that's because like their projection of
what work means to them is just so
negative and if I said all I do is play
video games all day then they would say
that I'm not working enough but what if
I my job was to play video games all day
then I'd be working too much it's just
like it's simply just their projections
of how they would prefer I live my life
their statement is I would prefer you
live your life the way I want you to
live your life to which I say
no so I live my life the way I want to
live it and that is
enough cool I love it okay cool thank
you man fantastic thank you guys that
was great it we're so happy to have you
on I want like I mean if it's not too
much to ask every year you know we the
recurring guest because look it we have
developments like last time it shoulds
now it's about because exactly that's a
huge change and I I bet you next time
there's going to be more exemptions
probably you know what I mean yeah I'm
going to eliminate I mean I try to
eliminate all labeling language but that
is a big then there's not even any is
just I mean yeah I mean that actually is
a big he is this well how about this
guys subscribe so that that way a year
from today will post another episode if
you want to be a part of it just hit the
like button and subscribe that's it and
it's free to subscribe it's all you have
to do it's free a deal the cost is
nothing the cost is a fraction of a
second for you to hit the button for
$100,000 I know exactly you got you got
uh actually
$150,000 wow so if you guys appreciate
$150,000 that we just gave you subscribe
and hit the like button and the
notification Bell like don't say I never
did nothing for it you know and all of
your information will be in the
description so enjoy yeah thanks cool
thanks guys till next time thank you
guys okay thumbnail or you think it's uh
I think we're
fine have you seen the office the show
yeah I got this haircut this morning
before the first podcast I thought I was
looking fly Graham said off the rip that
I look like Dwight shuit really off the
rip that I look but once you once you
see you can't unsee it kind of thing I
think that's that's kind of how I
describe it do I Tres yeah you look
older last time I saw you yeah yeah yeah
more wrinkles maybe a stress you you
might be stressed me I don't know this
guy's stressing I look older do I you're
36 33 are you really yeah okay thought
you were older than I was no okay yeah
I'm old I am developing wrink I actually
really want to get BOTOX do it then I
can't imagine it's healthy for you I
cannot imagine that injecting your body
with was it silicone no it's not silic
silicone what are you talking poison
it's not silic oh it's po I can't
imagine injecting yourself with poison
just neutralizes the muscle spul it's
literally the most deadly thing on earth
is it actually you could kill all of
humanity with this much of it see I
just I just actually yeah 100% it's like
Theo deadly botulin is what it's called
botulinum or something and Botox is it
botulism no it's like botulinum I think
yeah